this is Jocko podcasts number 116 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing good
evening I come good evening
so this then was the culmination to die
die in the stinking mud twice before I'd
crossed this no-man's land
darting from shell hole to shell hole
I'm no hero I was numb with fear but
this time a barrage was on I lay there
at the wastelands edge thinking was
there any way to the right lay crack
shot
snipers to the left in the brush machine
guns hungry waiting and fair in the
front great bursting mud clouds playing
toss with bodies get through once more
son the colonel had said communications
down our guns firing short killing our
boys yes it must be done but how wait
the barrage sweeping across the field
and back
a deadly windshield wiper were I to
follow it down and when I returned dig
in I might now drunk with fighting fear
I chased the mud cloud down the field
kicking dead bodies twisting like a
ghost and I laughed and I yelled you
bastard you can't get me our trenches
ahead almost there
back came hell's windshield-wiper
vomiting death and I dug in
dug in with all I had mom dear god help
me
on it came 40 feet 20 feet God my head
torn from my body is this what being
dead is like please quiet clean white
sheets my head must still be here
it hurts me these must be my fingers I
can move them and now a voice my boy for
you the war is over you hear that mom
I'm still alive I did not die I'm coming
home
and that is a poem that was written by a
man by the name of Ralph mone of East
Machias Maine who left his job as a
civil engineer in Waterville Maine to
enlist in the Army in 1917 and he was
wounded badly on that day but he did
live and he was decorated for his
actions on that day in the citation for
his award reads the President of the
United States of America authorized by
act of Congress 9 July 1918 takes
pleasure in presenting the Distinguished
Service Cross to mechanic Ralph T mone
United States Army for extraordinary
heroism in action while serving with
company K 100 and 3rd Infantry Regiment
26th division American Expeditionary
Force near Rayville France 26 September
1918 mechanic Mon who is detailed as a
runner made several trips carrying
important messages across terrain swept
by constant fire from machine guns
sniper's trench mortars and artillery
his disregard for personal safety and
devotion to duty in the prompt delivery
of messages contributed greatly to the
success of the action and Ralph mone
according to his family never spoke of
the war to his children or his
grandchildren but he did live with it
every day
and tonight I am honored to have a guest
back on the podcast who is also wounded
in war but who has not let that stop him
in any way
from driving on with his mission and his
life and doing more than most people
could ever even imagine mr. Rob Jones a
Marine
a wounded warrior and an inspiration to
anyone that's lucky enough to come into
contact with him Rob Jones welcome back
to the show
hey you know what it's a an honor to be
just a single time guest on what I
consider to be the best podcast on the
airwaves but to be a two-time guest is
purely rarefied air and I'm just I
appreciate you guys deeming me worthy of
a second visit so AB seen compared to
that gentleman is even greater honor so
yeah you know I read that a while back
and it was one of those things as I was
reading it I was thinking I was thinking
about you I was thinking about you know
I was thinking about Jodi thinking about
Travis think about you guys that were
more wounded bad and and I've heard that
before and another is another book I've
read about World War one where guys they
wake up they think they're in heaven
because they see white sheets and they
see you know there's a nurse there
that's talking nicely to him they think
they're dead they think they're in
heaven and that that reminded me you
know when I read that I was thinking
about you and and and haven't went
waking up you know in a hospital
somewhere and I know you actually woke
up you're not supposed to wake up in
Germany but you did know you're not
supposed to but yeah for whatever reason
I woke up I think I need to drink a
water so ya need to hydrate yeah I'm not
sure why I woke up I don't remember much
but and I didn't definitely didn't see
anybody you could mistake for an angel
squad leader well for anyone that's
listening that hasn't listened to the
first time Rob was on go back and listen
to episode 92 and that's where we go
through what Rob went through how he's
raised you know growing up to join the
Marine Corps deployment to Iraq
deployment to Afghanistan and that's
that's where Rob was wounded hidden I II
D
and ended up losing both legs above the
knee but like I said that didn't stop
Rob and he went from that and in the
podcast we jumped really quickly through
sort of your healing process right and
we jump right into the fact that you
were went out did the the Paralympics as
a rower and we jumped into the fact that
you rode a bicycle across America which
is yeah across America during the polar
vortex by the way yeah that's all that
stuff hasn't covered in 92 but I was I
was actually going back and I was
listening to 92 and I realized that you
know maybe it's just your it's your
attitude that might have might have made
me kind of do this in the conversation
your attitude is like yeah I lost both
my legs and then I was just competing in
the Paralympics you know you made it
sound like it's like it was like it was
easy that's that's a way it kind of came
across in the podcast and and what I
wanted to do today was kind of at least
go back and talk a little with a little
bit more detail about that process of
going because it's a long process right
year and a half yeah for me anyway yeah
yeah a year and a half of from letting
the wounds heal all the way through you
know we're now you're you're competing
in the Paralympics and you're getting
around and you're mobile and all that so
you get back how long does it take for
your wounds
cuz you can't do anything into your
wounds are healed up right no I mean
well you can do some stuff you can't do
anything as far as prosthetics are
confer are concerned so in the beginning
you know the the physical therapist
would come in and they just basically
just have me move my stumps around and
that would be like you know left your
right stump ten times left your left one
move it out and back and then that would
be it for the day or you know I could do
you know my arm still work so I would do
little pull-ups on my little trapeze bar
that I had attached to the the bed but
yeah I was you know surgeries every
other day they just come in and take me
over and they just be just cleaning the
wound out any dead tissue or anything
that was still left in there they
cleaned that out but I had these wound
vac
Sheen's on that were just constantly
sucking the fluids out of the wounds
because they were they were open for the
first month and yeah so they're just
like kind of sucking that stuff out and
it's just a you know waiting game at
that point I mean you're you can do some
stuff like I figured out how to it
slowly got it kind of three figured out
how to move my body around and move my
legs around and get comfortable on were
you getting like the Phantom Pain's yeah
I didn't get it as bad as Travis at it I
never had to do a what was it a ketamine
coma in order to I had it some and they
gave me this stuff called lyrica which
is like a fibromyalgia medication mm-hmm
and I got it and I never really had it
all that bad it's like it's pretty much
at the same level it is it is is now
where every maybe twice a day my toe
will kind of like hurt pretty bad for
four or five seconds and that's it but
there's some people that have it a lot
worse so I kind of lucked out with that
but yeah so first month just kind of
learning how to get into the wheelchair
you know at first I wouldn't I couldn't
I was so sore I couldn't really move
very much
so I would have to have a nurse and
whoever was in there visited me if I
wanted to get my wheelchair I'd be
sitting on this thought pad mm-hmm and
I'd say oh I want to go for a roll and
then so they would the nurse would be on
one side and the other person would be
on this side and they kind of like scoot
me onto the wheelchair and then we'd
have to take the wound back machines and
hook them onto the wheelchair and take
my catheter which I was very very
protective of that catheter hang that on
there and then the IV pole would have to
come with me and so then I would just
kind of roll myself around the ward a
couple times with you know my dad or my
mom or somebody pushing the IV pole and
yeah I just do that a couple times then
I'd go see my buddy Daniel because he
couldn't get out of bed yet
so I go and see visit him for a little
bit and I go back to my room and that'd
be pretty much my exercise for the day
and then have like six milkshakes
this eating as much as I possibly could
to help with the healing process you
know where did you go through the whole
woe is me why did this happen to me did
you go through that at all
and I mean I know I've listened some of
your stuff and reading some of your
stuff you know you talked about the fact
that you knew you had to just move to
like an acceptance phase right
immediately is that is that what you did
I mean how did you get look man people
hit all kinds of freaking roadblocks in
life and and very few of them are as
heavy of and big of a roadblock as you
hit and you seem to power through that
thing like miraculously you know I don't
I never I never extend to an extended
period that could be described as like a
depression or what was me you know
feeling sorry for myself it would come
in very short waves where you know I'd
be I'd be sitting around I would
struggle with something maybe and then
after I figured it out I might sit there
for a couple of minutes me like but
that'd be about it and that would be go
away after you know minute or two it'd
be kind of like I almost kind of like if
you're if you're talking to a girl in a
bar and you like your voice cracked you
just totally blow it and you look like
an idiot and then you go back to the TV
like man like that it was almost kind of
like that I missed that
ie D you know man this sucks but and I
you know I didn't really think about it
probably this way at the time I couldn't
articulate it at the time like this but
it's like that whether or not you know I
deserved yeah you know I did I could
acknowledge I didn't deserve it I didn't
deserve to be a double amputee I didn't
it wasn't you know fair there was a lot
of other guys that were running around
in that same exact area they didn't step
on it so it wasn't necessarily fair that
I had to be in NEP you t I didn't want
to be an amputee but no
that mattered it did none of that had
any bearing on whether or not I wanted
to have an enjoyable life and I did i
sat there I was like well what is my
mission in life if you really take it to
its base level you know have an impact
enjoy my life that doesn't change just
because now I'm an amputee and whether
or not it's fair or the fact that I'm
starting from a you know a little bit
more of a disadvantaged position now all
that stuff has no bearing on whether or
not I want to accomplish my mission and
so realizing that you just kind of well
what do I have to do now is that stuffs
in the past so all I can really affect
is how I react to it and you know so I
think that's kind of how I I skipped all
that stuff did you I know one one thing
that I remember and you know one of my
guys Ryan job he got he got shot in the
face and he got gravely wounded and you
know he ended up blind and he wants down
with a lot of casualties that had guys
that had really bad brain injuries right
and he was there for a little while and
you know these were guys that had been
severely wounded and like I said had
severe brain injuries so they're having
trouble communicating they're having
trouble with motor skills and and these
almost all the time come with other
physical injuries and you know his
attitude was hey look I'm taking up a
bed here and and we should give it to
someone else these guys are having a
much harder time than me I'm lucky
because I didn't get that injury all I
got was blind and you know some some
some damage to my face but right it was
a it was amazing to me to see a guy like
Ryan job who who just looked at him
itself and said I'm lucky I'm lucky
those guys are worse off than me try and
give your efforts to take care of these
other
guys instead of trying to take care of
me I can I can do okay open up this bed
for someone else to send me to send me
somewhere else and that's what they did
and I think that you know that attitude
of like hey this could be much worse
right and to me first of all hearing him
talk about that was was a testament to
like the spirit of a guy that just is
gonna carry on and drive on and yeah the
things that he did before he died or was
amazing you know he graduated college
with like with like a straight a grade
point average he got married he you know
his wife got pregnant his he got a job
with a defense contract him he was like
totally on the path and crushing it
despite the fact that he had you know
one of the best excuses
someone could have hey I got wounded I
lost my vision it didn't didn't slow him
down at all he'd climb around Mount
Ranier he just did amazing things and
his attitude of look I'm in a bad place
not that bad I'm gonna push on and like
you said this isn't gonna this isn't
gonna stop me from having a great life
and getting after it basically ya know
couple things uh I'm glad you brought
that up because it there's definitely
something to my own recovery during the
time where I got there so it's kind of
like I almost had a feedback loop on
myself so I got I was immediately
thinking about even in the blast crater
I was like one of my first thoughts was
like my mom's gonna be pretty upset
about this and when I woke up in Germany
the one thing that I did was I asked for
a stupid hat I was like my squad leader
is there I said see if you can find a
stupid look in a hat that I can wear
when I come out of the ambulance so that
when my mom sees me for the first time
she'll see this stupid hat and maybe
it'll make her laugh a little bit you
know but you know obviously they didn't
find one and but I think what happened
was I had a good attitude in the first
week or two and then that kind of set a
precedent for myself and all my friends
that came in all my family that came in
saw me with that solid positive attitude
and that you know that gave them hope at
the same time so they had that hope and
then I kind of went on and there was
times you know they saw me already like
that so if there was ever a time where I
was feeling sorry for myself or anything
like that I was like you know what my
mom my dad all these people have already
seen me being positive and if I flip
that around then that's gonna hurt them
now and so I have to keep that in mind
so when I'm it's not really about well
it's not only about me so that force
mice that's forced me to make sure I
maintain my positive attitude because
you know they're depending on me I'm
depending on them at the same time so
they're depending on me to stay positive
so that they can stay positive and so it
can't we kind of fed off each other and
so you know that just kind of snowballs
I guess until you know here we are now
you get so you're talking like a month
of milkshakes
and good milk they weren't mint
chocolate chip but they were good you
know and you're just feeding yourself
you're you're trying to try to heal up
get the wounds to actually heal and
you're every time you go around every
time you leave your bed it's a gut check
because you got a you know do the the
wound draining and all that other stuff
and then after a month things are
starting to heal up at what point did
yous were you able to like get yourself
out get yourself in the wheelchair I
think I was probably after that first so
I was I spent a week in the ICU you know
high on morphine I don't remember much
of that that time period and then I get
to the ward and probably after that
first week maybe ten days on the main
ward I'd be like all right I'm gonna try
and do this myself guys and then it took
five times the length of time but I did
it and then from that on I was doing it
on my own and so yeah that and that was
kind of the biggest milestone
for you know being in the hospital too
during that healing period was being
able to do that and then so and then you
know as they slowly took tubes away and
then the final milestone for being in
the hospital at that point was when my
wounds were finally sutured closed and I
got the skin graft I'd take a skin graft
from my left leg and put it on the
inside of my right thigh and once they
did that and that was they healed that
they checked it out made sure it was
good then I was ready to be transferred
over to wall three but I still had
stitches all in my or staples staples or
stitches wanted to and so after that was
done that's when they transferred me
over to Walter Reed and even then I
still had to wait for those stitches to
come out before I could get fitted for
prosthetics and I was probably in the
inpatient hospital for another two weeks
while I waited for a room to open up in
the outpatient housing so was pretty
similar in those first two weeks I just
had the IV line that's all I had and you
know I can go out are they pumping you
with antibiotics the whole time or what
are they what do they got an IV in you
for um pain medication okay and I think
it's probably just too standard they
just in case something goes wrong like
and they have quick access my buddy
Daniel he had a PICC line like straight
into his heart what's that it's just I
think it's just a a tube they just put
it straight put it into your chest and I
guess maybe it's just for quicker access
for pain medication so I'd be in the
hospital that first month and you know
they gave you the pain button so you can
kind of control yourself
and to be funny because they they it
only meters out so much in an hour you
can hit it like once every five minutes
or something but in the first week I'd
be kind of passing out and I whenever I
woke up I'd hit it a couple times just
to make sure I get in that dosage
because I was scared like what happens
if this pain button goes away like I
don't want to face that and so they'd
come in after an hour in the nurses say
you know you can only hit this thing
once every five minutes yeah yeah I know
the way you've hit it like 200 times the
last hour
oh you know I just hit it just you know
I call asleep yeah
and so then during that time when you
when you were still had like stitches
but and I know we talked about this a
little bit but you had like the triangle
thing hanging above you you start doing
pull-ups and you start trying to do some
kind of upper body workout at that time
yeah I mean once I got to Walter Reed I
met my physical therapist that day and
we set up the time I was gonna come in 7
o'clock for occupational therapy and
eight o'clock for physical there and
we'd be just doing stuff on the mat
tables so you don't have to be boring
legs you can be working on other stuff
while you're waiting for that stuff to
heal so yeah I'd be doing kind of dips
I've raised my the arms and my
wheelchair up really high and I do dips
and you know they had stuff you could do
like trunk strengthening exercises you
know I wasn't the first double above
knee amputee to come through Walter Reed
you know we've been at war for nine
years so they had this all these
exercises already set up so I'd come in
I do my exercises lay no legolas for the
day and just work on what I could while
we waited for that stuff too while we
waited for my skin and we're just
waiting on my skin basically to heal how
did you feel like how did you feel
regaining your strength in your upper
body were you like were you like back on
the Gaines path you know what I mean
were you like okay I just did you know
yesterday I did eight pull-ups and today
I'm gonna do ten and the next day I'm
gonna did you get did you get yourself
right back in like the old school
workout mode fro yeah uh just back on
the path yeah man when I was still in
when I was still in the hospital at
Bethesda I I would go into physical
therapy you guys got a pull-up bar or
anything like that and yeah we have one
they had one in like a closet and I was
and I was like I wanna do some pull-ups
and so I set the pull-up record for
people that had come through and it got
broken by a seal later but uh so yeah I
set that pull-up was like let me see how
I never lost the desire to see what I
could do you know I was like yeah I'm
gonna do a Mac set up whoops and see how
many I could do still but yeah it was
definitely frustrating because I I was
lost a lot of muscle mass but you know
once you started doing those exercise
like every time I came in I wanted to go
one more or two more or a little bit
longer and I had that same attitude when
I started walking you know the first day
I started walking I'd maybe stood in my
legs for two minutes the next day I was
like you know I'm gonna try three
minutes today or last yesterday I walked
one time around the little track I'm
gonna go twice
you know just slowly building up and you
know kept that same so what does that
process like getting getting standing up
for the first time what does that feel
like it's well I mean the first thing
you got to do is you got to get casted
so they have to make the sockets that go
on to your stumps and they do it they
make they they wrap this plaster around
your stump and they mold it so that it's
putting pressure on the right spots and
they take that off they fill it up with
some other kind of plaster material they
take the the cast they made off and then
they pour plastic around that and so
then you have your basically the mold of
your leg and the first time you the
first time you step up in and it is not
comfortable at all it hurts a lot
because you're putting pressure on
points that you didn't before and they
kind of have to so you stand up and
you're like okay well there's a spot
right back there that hurts a lot so
they take it off and they use this hair
dryer make it hot and they kind of mold
it they push it out against so it's not
against that spot anymore and then you
put it back on okay that's comfortable
and then you do if the other one and for
me yeah I mean I could you could you
can't
I couldn't just walk from the first try
I had to have my arms on the on the the
parallel bars like it was you know that
slow thing that you see kind of in in
movies where I took maybe ten steps and
that was it for my first time I've
walked five is it like balanced or is it
is the musculature like is it you're
using different muscles yeah so you
definitely you're walking in a different
way than your body's designed to so
when you walk you just go you know kind
of forward and back here with your legs
your been bend at the knee to get it
past the ground so he doesn't skip on
the ground whereas when you're double
above knee amputee you have to swing
your legs out to the side at first
because you don't have that knee joint
you can't just bring them you know
forward so you kind of have to learn
that and it's a lot of the balance your
your musculature has to kind of get used
to what muscles you're using to keep
your balance now so that has to be
figured out by your you know brain your
spinal cord and then on top of that just
developing the resistance to the the
discomfort this isn't really not
comfortable and that's kind of probably
what I didn't get tired like I could
have stood for longer but it's just my
legs we're hurting so bad yeah like you
could run a mile or you could run a
marathon or whatever but if you're if
you're if you have a blister on your toe
you know then that's gonna stop you yeah
it's it seems like the balance thing
like sometimes I've hurt my like let's
say hurt my ankle or hurt my even
something as stupid as hurt like I had a
big cut on my down the bottom of my foot
yeah and so you can't use your foot the
way you normally do and it totally
throws off your balance and I can't even
imagine you're you're now trying to
balance through the through the
perception of your nerves in your in
your stumps yeah and and how that feels
and how you gotta kind of adjust for
that that's got to be like learning how
to like ski or something learning how to
do a balance type sport surf or
something like that I can I can only
imagine that that's got to be what it's
like to get your brain and like you said
your brain your spinal cord to be able
to adapt to what's happening underneath
you when you you have a totally new set
of sensors down there now yeah and you
have to also keep have to keep it for a
double above knee amputee and all this
stuff I'm saying is just double
above-knee amputees but you're also
losing two joints that help with balance
so an able-bodied person they have if
they want to make a small adjustment use
their ankle and then they can use the
knee and then they can use the hip but
you know
above-knee we all we have is the hip so
it's an extra challenge learning how to
make these adjustments with just just
your hips but you know it's kind of it's
a lot like a a dog that has a missing
leg you know the first time he goes to
walk he kind of just figures it out and
he his learns that new method and it's
kind of it's pretty much a similar thing
you you know you adapt to it and you
just do you figure it out
and on the first prosthetics that you
get are they articulated or they just
like straight because I know what you've
got now is pretty they look pretty damn
advanced to me yeah yeah you're looking
like freaking Terminator robot over
there so you get that first because is
it articulating because no so yeah it's
in the balance in that realm they keep
you really short while you're relearning
that balance because just in case you
fall so while you're relearning that
balance it keep you really short so
basically I could do if I was gonna fall
I just put my hand out pretty much and
catch myself on the ground and so while
you're reading this balance they keep
you nice and short because your center
gravity is gonna be lower so it's a lot
easier and then also you kind of learn
that hit motion so they keep you nice
and short just to make it a lot easier
and then as you get better as you get
stronger and a little bit better moving
around they make you a little bit taller
but there's no need it's just uh you go
from your socket and there's a straight
cylindrical pylon made out of metal and
that goes to the prosthetic foot and you
probably have a shoe on the foot and
then that's it so you you stay really
short for three four months and at this
time are you already thinking about like
what kind of crazy stuff you're gonna do
once you figure this shit out I once I
had found out about the Paralympics that
was probably my first week when I was at
Bethesda in the hospital bed just
researching I wanted to get back in the
gym and I didn't know what I could what
I'd still be able to do in the gym so I
was maybe looking for forget what I
searched but like disabled sports are
disabled working out or something like
that and I found the Paralympics
and at the time I wasn't saying to
myself I'm definitely gonna commit to
going because I didn't know much about
and I still had this big I still had to
take you know a year and a half to
relearn how to walking and that was
numero uno to learn how to do but yeah
it was kind of in the back of my head I
found about it I was thinking about
that's kind of how things work for me I
like the idea is impregnated initially
and okay okay that's an interesting idea
you know paralympics okay that's
interesting I'll ride my bike
cross-country okay interesting and then
I think about it a little bit more and
time goes on yeah I could probably do
that you know and then eventually I'll
get to a point where like alright I'm
gonna do it and then I commit to it and
so at this point you know I hadn't
committed to it but I was researching
and you know contemplating and figuring
out the feasibility and you know how I
would go about it if I wanted to try and
make the attempt that seems like that
would have a massive positive impact on
your mindset so something that I talked
about I talked about with the Jordan
Peterson and he agreed with me on this
idea of finding a new mission and having
a new mission so a lot of times I'm sure
you've seen this - I've definitely seen
it when guys get out of the military for
whatever reason when they get out the
guys that do well are the guys that have
a new mission to go on and whether it's
a new job or whether they're gonna be a
super dad or whether they're gonna go to
school and get good grades those guys do
good and well in their new mission the
guys that have the most trouble from
what I've seen most of the time is the
guys that don't have a new mission
they're they get out and they say well
you know I might do this I might do that
I might do something else but what
they're really doing is nothing they
don't have any real direction and they
end up you know
what's the mission the mission becomes
have another drink you know do something
unproductive do what feels good
immediately and it becomes problematic
but it seems like the fact that you
found something immediately you realize
that there was a goal that you could go
after even if it was only a little idea
at first yeah that idea can carry you a
long way yeah and you know also luckily
for me it
wasn't like it was it's not like I was
in Afghanistan one day and then
separated the next day I kind of had a
mission that was you know it came about
about by its own because you know I just
lost my legs so that my first mission
was learn how to walk so I had that
right away but you know while I was
taking that time to do that I was
thinking about you know what I'm gonna
do after I get out you know every every
guy that gets out of the military you
know most the time you know when your
contracts gonna end so you can start
thinking about earlier but it's
definitely you know I agree with you
having having something to work towards
is hugely important see I'll tell you
that even what you just said so there's
people that they they get out and you're
saying hey I had this new mission
because I had to at least learn how to
walk there's there's people that they
get out and they don't have a new
mission and they don't figure one out
and that becomes so problematic and and
you know what let's not just apply it to
the military I'll apply this to every
human being happy and kids get out of
college happens when kids get out of
high school happens when you go through
you know you've got something that
you're looking at or something that
you're focused on in boom it goes away
well now what are you gonna do and if
you don't line something up and don't
focus on something you don't take aim at
something well then you're not going
anywhere
oh yeah like one year you know how you
shoot do you guys call it Table two when
you're kind of working on shooting like
targets that are right in front of you
we don't call it okay we call it table
two as table one is kind of the long
distance rough arrange okay but it's
almost kind of like when you're when are
you doing that and you they say okay
shoot this guy twice and that guy twice
oh you do that and then at the end you
scan and make sure there's nobody else
around so it's kind of like doing that
your mission is to shoot the thing but
you also have to be looking out for
other stuff yeah yeah no absolutely you
know it's it's funny too because I think
about like when you think about kids
that you grew up with and like high
school they get done with high school
and there's some kids that okay I'm
gonna go into college I'm gonna go to
military yeah there's some kids that
don't know what they're gonna do after
high school and what happens to it you
know what happens to him they flounder
around they get a little job here that
they don't
really like they do something else they
don't really like you just have to be
careful of that yeah you have to be
careful and I'd say as a parent that's
just something to look out for too
you know you got to look out for your
kids and make sure your kids have
something to focus on have something
that they're striving for because if you
don't have anything to strive for if
you're not trying to go anywhere if
you're not on some kind of mission
that's this problematic yeah and you
know since I had that everything I did
during the day mattered to me because I
had something that was vastly important
to me that I was trying to achieve so if
I didn't care about whether or not I
walked again then I could just roll
around in my wheelchair and it wouldn't
matter if I worked out that day but
since I really learned how to walk again
and be totally independent and get rid
of my wheelchair and all that stuff to
be able to run and do everything I was
able to do before that was you know the
most important thing and so I fed off
that when you know I didn't feel like
going into therapy because I was my back
hurt or whatever and the you know
whether or not I do that third fourth
set of balance drills or you know
strengthening exercises you know that
had an effect on on that goal and and so
and the same thing with going to the
Paralympics you know I wanted to be able
to to explore that and so the stuff I
was doing in the hospital it mattered so
this is interesting because we were
actually talking about this the other
day so you end up with and again I'm
just trying to break down because
obviously you're a person that that can
push through pain and suffering and push
through short term challenges in order
to achieve a long term goal and I I
think that the way you break it down is
you're looking even when you're you're
suffering from a challenge right now
you're you're you know I don't feel like
doing another balance tree drill because
my back is sore or whatever yeah well
people hit that those kind of obstacles
every single day you know they don't
want to get up in the morning they don't
want to
gal that I want to do the last set a
setter eccentric setter but you had you
tie those small term short-term things
the short-term pain because you have a
long-term goal that's do you really care
about yeah exactly I mean it's it's all
a matter of what matters to you most you
know is what's more important to you
learning for me learning how to walk
again or staying in bed today you know
staying a bit would be nice it would
feel good I'd be able to watch I think
what I was watching on Netflix I was
watching 24 the series at the time on
that play so I could watch that entire
series of 24 today or something and I
could do that and that would be fun but
at the end of the day I'm still not
gonna be any closer to being able to
walk again and I would much rather be
able to walk everywhere I went totally
independently then find out what happens
to Jack Bauer you know so and then you
know at the same time you know with if
you're working on you know what people
like to do if you want to lose weight
you know do you would you rather have a
milkshake mint chocolate chip milkshake
or would you rather cook cookie dough
milkshake would you rather have that
milkshake or would you rather you know
be able to run ten miles or not get
winded when you're walking with your
kids or being playing with your kids is
that what which one matters to you more
and I always pick that bigger one
because I mean it's pretty
straightforward for me yeah you did the
delayed gratification
it's the delayed gratification versus
the instant gratification delayed but
much more enjoyable yeah much more
durable definitely better and better for
your whole life yeah last longer too by
the way
yeah yeah and enduring it's an enduring
lasting longer lasting enduring thing
that you end up with mm-hmm that's what
people need to tap into that right there
that's good how you have a like a way
like almost like a I don't say
scaffolding but like a way to look at it
it's like how you when you're presented
with like an option you're a your
just be you have a way to look at it
where you're like okay which one is
important to me which one you know is
Jack Bauer and 24 important yeah or is
walking important to you know so most
people they just go on how they feel you
know I really don't feel like doing this
so I'll do this or I really am in the
mood for this so I'll do it kind of
thing they don't like kind of in a way
break it down like how you do just yeah
just from moment to moment where you'll
be like okay I have this way to look at
it and I'm look at it this way and then
I can read behave you know yeah that
actually that's pretty a good way of
looking at it you put it into a binary
calculation yeah right just there's two
options yeah don't go like am I get a
view the thing that's gonna make make me
better in the long run or the thing
that's gonna make me worse in the long
run and feels good right now which one
are you gonna do did you just make that
into a binary decision yeah but you
really so simple which one's important
to me and it's it's almost like a black
or white drives you what's driving your
behavior and then you can even take
another step like again like the losing
the weight example yeah you you will
either want to have the milkshake or you
want to be able to you know walk around
you guys even if you don't care about
you know being overweight or you're not
being able to move your body around you
know you can still lose the weight by
figuring out what even if you don't feel
like going on a diet like what is it
that necessitates you to go on the diet
and for me so I didn't want necessarily
to train every day for the Paralympics I
didn't necessarily want to ride my bike
every day on my bike ride or run him I
didn't necessarily enjoy doing that I
didn't feel like doing it but I had to
do that because my goal necessitated me
to do that so if you're struggling to
get motivated to lose weight just for
the sake of losing weight find something
that necessitates you to lose weight
that really matters to you like you know
not dying when you're 55 of a heart
attack
that'll do it there's there's three
things that you talked about on the lot
well we talked about on the last podcast
but I
breathe breezed over them and I realized
when I listen to it again I should have
talked to you a little bit more in depth
because I think it's helpful for people
to hear again to hear from you who's
overcome incredible challenges there's
three things that you talked about and
it's actually in the journal which you
have a journal online on Rob Jones
journey calm but and this is there as
well but number one is writing down
goals number two is celebrating
milestones at number three is overcoming
rationalization so let's just break
those down a little bit how strict were
you with writing down your goals and do
you still do that I don't I guess I
don't physically you'll have a pen and
paper and write it down I think what I
do now is I'll announce it or something
like that or I'll make it known that
that's what I'm planning on doing track
so when I decided to do my marathon
challenge I did it on Facebook or
something or I put it on all my social
media platforms and then it's out there
now okay now i'm responsibie this is
beyond writing it down yeah this is like
writing it down to the world yeah
telling people that you want to have the
respect of like if I told my wife Pam
like I am gonna do this and she she
knows I'm a person that she respects me
for living up to what I say I'm gonna do
I don't want to lose her respect so now
I'm even even though I would have done
it regardless aying I would have said I
would do it and then that fall out or
back out on another mission even if the
mission became not important to me
there's another another aspect of that
you know you you've committed to it and
then so that's another aspect of my
personality where not only do I want to
help veterans but now I've committed to
some I said I'm gonna do and I've given
my word and now there's people that are
kind of relying on me to to do that and
if I if I say I'm gonna do it then I say
oh never mind I actually not gonna do it
and they're actually losing a little bit
of hope maybe because they were they
were hoping I was going to do it they
were gonna get something out of it now
now they're I'm not doing it so they're
kind of losing that
benefit yeah make sense yeah so it's
beyond writing it down it's writing it
down and announce it announcing it
celebrating milestones yeah so it's
really hard to stay motivated when
there's this obscure goal that is two
years away or a year and a half away and
you're not really seeing huge progress
towards everybody you're getting like a
millimeter every day it gets old
yeah you feel really motivated in the
beginning right cuz you're pumped up and
you have tons of energy and then when
you and at the end you can see it you
can smell the barn you can see it so you
find the extra energy in your in
yourself but in that that middle part
where you're not you're not even sure
that you're gonna be able to do it and
it's so far away like man I'm only like
halfway and I still have I've done all
this stuff and now I still have to do
all that again it helps to pick stuff
along the way that you know is going to
to be there that kind of you know
alright I'm not I'm going for that far
away thing but right now I'm going to
that and that's what excites me so when
I was in the hospital getting in the
wheelchair was my first little milestone
yeah I had a year and I didn't even know
how long was gonna take me to learn how
to walk again
at least I was thinking a year and a
half two years you know that's a long
time and with a lot of work in between
so alright right now just get into the
wheelchair and then alright well learn
how to do it on your own and then after
that get your legs and then figure out
how to walk with only one cane instead
of two canes keeping you up and then
drop the other cane and that's another
milestone and then you get your bionic
knees then so you probably go back to
the canes for a while and then when you
have those you take away that cane and
then take away the other one and then
you learn how to run and then you learn
how to do ride the bike or whatever so
you just keep finding little things
along the way and you know when I was
doing when I was training for triathlons
I do this on a small scale
I would have eight 2-minute all-out
sprints on my bike to do I'd be sitting
there on the first one I'm like oh my
god I have eight of these to do that the
first one just blow me up like I have
seven more and I would just be like you
know what just focus on this next one
just do this one and then we'll focus on
the next one after that and then so does
and I would even trick myself sometimes
I'd be like all right I'll be on my
sixth one I'd be so tired arc you know
what if I can maintain this speed or if
I can make my power maintain my power
output for this entire seventh one I'll
skip the eighth one but I'll treat
myself I'll skip the eighth one I do the
seventh one over that alright I'll just
do the eighth one cuz you know yeah so
it's interesting so what you've talked
with this dichotomy in these in this
thing and I've talked about this before
I've talked about before multiple times
I don't even know if I've talked on the
pot I must talk about on the podcast but
I've talked I talk about it with people
which is you have long range stuff and
you have short range enough and what you
have to do is you have to put the both
those in your mind and you have to shift
the focus back on for back and forth
between the two to whichever one is
gonna get you moving
because when the goal is too far away
you're like hi you know one it's not
gonna really make a difference if I skip
this thing today it's not that big of a
deal
the goal is too far away it gets blurry
and and so what you need is you need to
put okay just two up do the short goal
well after the daily grind beats you
down on the short goal you start to
forget what the long-term goal isn't you
guys you know what I don't lean do you
do this workout today or I don't need to
D I can eat this food or I can do
whatever because it's not gonna make a
big impact on the long face what am i
doing anyways yeah then you're gonna
look back at the long gone that's right
I have this this thing that I'm trying
to make happen and it's these small
goals that are gonna get me there so you
got a shift you gotta have both the
long-term goal that's got to be
something that you really want to
achieve you got to understand why you
know like you said you got to understand
why it is you want to achieve it you
can't just be something that you don't
care about and then you're gonna have
that as your primary driving force but
your secondary driving force which is
equally important is these short-term
things that you can get to that are
there that are close
you can achieve even if it's two minutes
even if it's I did Tabata
Tabata on the air bike the other day bro
yeah I was there I was like you know and
my daughter was there my wrestled my
daughter that wrestles she was there and
so she's kind of like calling me out but
in a positive way she's a positive
person Heitmann
yeah she was hyping me and I put out
heart cuz she was there oh come on you
know what it's like when you're your
daughter's going come on dad yes push
harder you like oh yeah I'm gonna get
something I wanted to die you know you
know the blood taste of your mouth you
know yeah yeah whatever that thing is so
I had some of that going on but but yeah
you have the short term and you have the
long term goals you got to have them
both and you got it
they've got to be attached somehow but
you've got to lean on which one is gonna
get you to do what you know you're
supposed to do you know you're supposed
to do that's a little psychology behind
just getting after it
yeah right yes the little psychology
behind just getting after it little head
games you echo and I were talking the
other day he was all he was kind of
surprised because I was talking about
there's there's a one workout that I do
which is but it's I it's my hardest and
most brutal workout and it's in it's in
the Field Manual but it's a 20 reps
squat you do you do you take a weight
that you can squat 10 times and you do
it 20 times and like after rep 12 every
single rep is just it just it's on its
pain and then you do that and then you
lay on the floor for 20 minutes and then
you get up and you do it again and then
you lay on the floor for 20 minutes and
you get up and do it again so it's three
sets in one hour it's not one hour
workout but I was telling Eko I was like
yeah there's times where I'm in the
middle of like set to and I'm on rep 14
and I'm like I don't even I don't even
think I want to be strong I don't want
to be strong I don't even care if I'm
healthy I just wanna I just wanna just
this is this is horrible why would I be
doing this right now
this is stupid yeah really freaking
relief but but actually what gets me to
push through those is I think to myself
oh you hear that that's actual weakness
in your mind right now actual living
weakness gets a voice in your mind right
now how are you gonna listen to it are
you gonna listen to it no you're not
gonna listen to it are you doing them
straight through or yes that's it's it's
an old-school workout that I originally
got from well there's a book called
super squats good stuff there's a book
called super squats if and that book has
this workout but actually that book only
has you do one set you do one set I was
the idiot that thought to myself well if
one set is good how about I do three
sets of that and it's brutal it's brutal
yeah and once you think of it it's like
all I have to do it now ya know that's
another thing that's another thing I say
is is you know if you don't really feel
like working out okay that's fine write
down what you're gonna do and then just
do it just just turn off your brain and
just do what you're supposed to do just
put the numbers down and do what you're
supposed to do you're not every day is
all happy you know this is great I need
to feel myself getting stronger no I
feel like I'm gonna puke that's not cool
but that's good that's like a like kind
of like you're talking about how if you
go by how you feel every day like I feel
like doing this or really motivate or
feeling we're just like are you're
saying wrong or you you are in the habit
of looking at it a certain way like
what's important to me okay how you feel
it's kind of shuffled to the side like
what's important okay now I'm gonna get
moving
yeah feelings are not not bad generally
not a good thing to rely on to make
things yeah and really not agree but it
can trick you though you know like just
like are you saying in the beginning you
know when you first decide to do
something yeah you know like new year's
resolution whatever you know like it's
real common thing we're at the beginning
exciting let's start this new thing and
then at the end it can be because you
see the goal right there we're about to
do it you know kind of thing but in the
middle it's like yeah so feeling can I
don't want to say yeah you're you're
right don't rely on it but it can trick
you because in the beginning when you
have that feeling like you want to it's
like some
do you think it's gonna be there the
whole time yeah this is the new thing
from me I mean I've never felt anything
like this about anything I've ever done
I'm excited about this one then he goes
away thinking like we're not doing that
you always had that energy at the end
like uh I bet like the last oh yeah have
you guys ever heard of the central
governor theory of fatigue no well it's
basically about it's a different so see
if I can do this without making it super
long there's two different we got eight
hours of recording time but there's two
different 18 theories on how your body
I guess processes fatigue or what it
exactly it is and so there's the I think
it's called the catastrophic theory or
basically you're during you Tabares and
something breaks down and then like
you've run out of energy totally deplete
yourself of glycogen or whatever and
then you you can't yet you don't have
any more glycogen see muscles don't work
and then there's this other theory which
is kind of the accepted theory now that
your brain has a governor in it and it's
it's getting all this information from
your muscles and your senses all that
it's getting all this information it's
calculating how much energy it meters
out and so when you're doing your Tabata
the first one you have all sorts of
energy so your brains like go and it's
connected to your subconscious and your
constant to kind of connect so you kind
of know how many sets you do and your
brain actually calculate that's
calculates of that into its how it
decides to do this so that first one Oh
tons of glycogen available to me so I
can just blow through this first one and
then as you go your your your brain is
getting these signals that you're
running you run out of glycogen maybe
the calcium to contract the muscles is
kind of getting low and so it kind of
dials you back automatically by
contracting less muscle fibers and so
you kind of get and it makes you feel
fatigued so they say that fatigue is
actually fatigue and pain are actually
motion so it makes you feel these
emotions for to use a lie fatigue so it
makes you feel this and it kind of dials
you back and then on that last one you
know that this is your last one so it's
like alright well we're done after this
so I'm gonna let it go and then so
that's the theory so yeah it's kind of
but so there this thing called the gold
I think I told you this gold g10 I think
I'm pronouncing it correctly Golgi
tendon organ little regulator and
they're essentially like clusters of
nerves that go in and so this is more
like high-intensity like I'm going to do
a two rep one wrap to wrap through your
wrap or whatever max so that's regulated
by your brain so when you get too much
stress on your muscle your brain says
hey that's too much stress you're gonna
stop the muscle contraction or let off
usually it stops it that's why if you go
for a two rep max one rep max you can
get it here and then you just Boop and
it fails you fail um but if you can get
the if it doesn't fire you go oh and
you'll push your push sometimes your
pause you know and you can still put
like why did you just fail the other
time you know I mean yeah it's that so
um and then if you go to lower intensity
stuff then it goes more into the glycan
like you ever seen like a marathon
runner or you know some real long like
an obstacle courses or the guys like
mentally you can tell he's he's not
gonna quit but his legs are like
shivering shaking and he it's like he's
almost like he's gonna pass out or
something like that yeah it so that's
more that that's like your physical
capability that energy the physical
energy system is failing that's you know
so that's a different thing so it's
funny though like I'm sure when you were
in bootcamp or going through buds like
how many pushups are you gonna do you're
just gonna keep doing push-ups you
literally just keep doing push ups and
push ups and push ups and push ups and
push ups and sometimes you lay there for
on flat on your face for like 20 seconds
but then they say keep going and so you
just keep going and then you you keep
going for a little while and then you
lay on your face for a little while and
then you keep going like you can just
keep going more mmhmm yeah unless you
get to that now sometimes on like a run
someone would pass out and
that would be that yeah what's that yes
the corner that's there would be your
your brain basically shuts you to so and
you see somebody running at the end of a
marathon and they're like their legs
aren't working that's kind of their body
they've been able to somehow push
through all the pain and all that stuff
they've been able to put they've been
motivated to push through and then
finally your body gets to a point if we
keep going we are going to die so I'm
shutting you down and it just hits the
hits the shutdown button and then your
legs are stopped right this it will just
stop contracting your muscles yeah or I
don't remember how we got on this
subject yeah pushing through yeah but
it's like the engine is still going but
the fuel doesn't get to the engine so
the engine starts you know a little
situation but in like a higher intensity
stuff it's it seems like you know given
what I want to know about the Golgi
tendon organ situation seems like you're
a Golgi tendon expert yes but well here
this is this is one I really I learned
about it in college but when I tore my
bicep no no guys will lift real hard and
just tear their muscle off their bone
yeah because when you train heavy you're
training to to do what he said to me
Gate the effects of the Golgi tendon are
that so or like huge rushes of
adrenaline will do it too you know you
hear the story about the the lady she
saw the car that's the car off the kid
yeah so basically you're just bypassing
the Golgi tendon organ because of these
extreme situations yeah but by nature
trail lift up a car you can't can't and
the same I mean the Bentley you know
that most of us can but when you do like
a one rep max like keeper when you test
for that you see it all the time where
you know the guy let's say I don't know
he does 355 right like he even there's
like a pause because it's pushing so
hard and he's barely any guinea gets it
put on 365 pounds more he gets it like a
quarter the way up and it just falls off
his chest you know because it fires and
boom muscles shut down that's what that
is yeah and when you're doing the heavy
you're also teaching you're kind of
teaching your body to like you most
people can only contract 30% of their
muscles at one time because their brain
doesn't let them because if they
contracted all of your muscle fibers at
the same time it could produce an injury
yeah so when you lift head
be your brain is kind of learning
alright I can I can contract this many
okay now I can contract this many and
like the best people still can only
contract like 50 percent yeah their
their muscles like Olympic lifters yeah
that's like because they're just yeah
exactly like really heavy power lifters
yeah so now on the on the last podcast
we talked about the Paralympic growing
so and we talked about you biking across
across the country again which is from
Maine to San Diego and when and again if
people want to people should go listen
to those on on podcast 92 and but but
when you were on last time you were
talking about your latest announcement
your latest goal that you had written
down and announced everybody which was
that you were going to run thirty-one
marathons in 31 days which is just kind
of a little bit psycho and actually you
wrote down I'm gonna read this excerpt
from your from your online journal here
we go back to the journal I can't this
is an expression that is vilified in our
minds beginning at a young age every
time a young child announces this
decision they are corrected the first
adult that hears it ask them whether or
not they have even tried generally this
confrontation will result in the child
giving their task
another attempt until their attention
span moves on to something else the
adult will see this and chuckle to
themselves with knowledge that this is
just a child who is yet to learn the art
of art and virtue of perseverance by the
time this child comes of age however
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count that there
is no such thing as can't
it is interesting then to think about
how many adults seem to proclaim this
expression in their lives it is because
is it because like many things that
adults tell children they are simply
telling the child a general rule that
the child must follow but can be broken
once one has grown or is it because
these adults are simply repeating what
they were told as children without
thoroughly examining what the phrase I
can't
Trulli suggests if you confronted an
adult that claims they can't do
something with the same question about
whether or not they have tried the
answer will almost always be yes
adults have learned enough to know that
is unreasonable to say they can't until
they have at least tried once therefore
the real question that we should be
asking in responses
have you tried everything have you
exhausted every possible option scenario
combination tool and approach I do not
simply refer to the ones that you knew
of at the time you decided to undertake
your task I mean have you read also
researched possibilities that you had
known about have you determined whether
or not there is another person out there
that has performed the exact same task
you are attempting or at least something
similar have you exhausted this research
have you read every book blog journal
magazine bathroom stall and website if
the answer to any of these questions is
no then go back and try again because if
you don't because you don't truly know
if you can do something until you've
tried absolutely everything the fact of
the matter is that rarely if ever is the
answer to all these questions yes
therefore what is it that people
actually mean when they say I can't a
more accurate but more verbose way of
saying it would be I don't care about or
want enough this task or the resultant
benefits of it in order to do all that
is necessary to achieve it I was told
countless numbers of times by people
during my month of marathons that they
couldn't run one marathon let alone 31
straight every now and then when I had
time I would discuss what they'd said we
would jointly conclude that if something
they cared about and depended on them
doing so it would be possible the most
common example I used was if someone had
a gun to your child's head do you think
you could do it then
therefore the phrase I can't denotes a
lack of investment as opposed to a lack
of potential or ability I do not mean to
say that every person I had this
conversation with should have had the
motivation to run marathons it was
something that I decided to do not them
I merely wanted to express to them what
I am expressing here given the right
purpose and enough time you can what
happens if someone has said they can't
we have asked them if they've done
everything and the rare cases happen and
they honestly say yes do we concede that
then they can't nope if everything in
existence has been attempted enough to
determine that it won't work
then congratulations you've been awarded
the honor of being the person who must
invent the method or the tool or
determine the right combination whether
or not you will once again boils down to
how much you care and time amande up
being that a person ends up trying for
their entire life but I suggest removing
the phrase I can't from your lexicon and
replacing it with I can't yet do this so
that you don't risk being on your
deathbed saying I didn't so and I don't
mean to like if somebody comes up and
says I can't do something I'm not gonna
say I'm not gonna you know I know what
they're really saying and I don't I'm
not gonna judge I mean I don't care if
you if you don't care about this thing
it doesn't matter to me but you should
just be a little bit more accurate and
what you're saying you know I'm not like
if you if you say I can't run a marathon
that's fine that's fine you don't you
don't want to run a marathon you don't
care about running it doesn't matter to
you and that's your personal choice you
know but to say that you can't do it
having never even attempted it is just
not an accurate stay
so where'd you get the idea to attempt
thirty-one marathons in 31 days so and
after my bike ride I tried to make the
Paralympics for a triathlon and I did
not succeed I failed in that attempt but
with every failure there is a lesson
learned and I learned when I was
training for a triathlon that I was
pretty good at running I was able to run
the 5k triathlon 5k distance at the end
of the triathlon at 18 minutes flat
which is pretty fast that's that's
maxing out the Marine Corp EFT you can't
get any faster than that and so it's
pretty fast so and I realized you know I
I'm a decent decent talent for running
and I'd run the Marine Corps Marathon
the year before and I'd so I knew that I
could run a marathon and I was this kind
of you know after this failed attempt to
make the Paralympics because kind of
thinking about what my next mission
could be and I wanted to do another
thing like my bike ride and I had heard
about other people doing this kind of
thing where they do you know 50
marathons in 50 days in 50 states or if
the Iron Man's in 50 days of 50 states
so you know I decided I wanted to do
marathons and I kind of put my own
little spin on it and I said well you
know what I want to get this story and
in front of as many eyeballs as I can so
to do 50 mayor earth to do 31 marathon
straight in my backyard isn't really
gonna do that so I need to do I could go
down to the trail every day for 31
straight and do it and nobody would ever
care and nobody would ever find out
about it and it'd be the same amount of
it'd be just as impressive to do and so
I want to get this in front of as many
eyeballs as possible so I need to do it
in major cities where there's a lot of
people that can find out about it and
spread it that way and so I figured I'll
take that same formula and do 31
marathons in all in different cities and
I picked 31 because I was trying to
figure of a good number so I I started
with the 20 number which is the number
associated with number of veteran
suicides every day I figured
be a pretty powerful number but after
think about that I kind of figured it
wasn't enough it wasn't enough marathons
in a row and I figured by the time more
marathon City by the time I got started
with that I'd be and by the time I got
kind of some momentum going it pretty
much be over and so I didn't figure to
have as big an impact so I wanted to do
more so I was like well what about 50
and so I was like well okay 50 I could
probably do it if I trained enough for
it but 50 might be too many might be too
long so by the time I started getting
going and then I you know I'm at 40 I
still have 10 more people are gonna kind
of maybe lose interest and I was that
guy still doing that because I found out
about the iron cowboy doing his 50 iron
man's in 50 days and I kind of had that
same thing where oh hey this is gonna be
awesome I was falling for the first
couple weeks and then eventually I'm
like oh she still is he even finish it
oh wow I kind of lost it so I'm like
alright well what if I just did it for a
month I think people could probably pay
attention for a month and will really be
interested for a month before they
really move on so they all right month
ok month of marathons and longest month
is 31 so I picked 31 and I have to say
when know you're doing you know what
you're doing is hard when you come on
jaakko podcast and he says this is
insane
Jaakko willing says something insane you
know it's it's the right level of
intensity so what kind of miles did you
put in to get ready for it and how long
did you train for it my total I trained
about 18 months for this specifically
and I say that knowing that I had been
an athlete training just about twice a
day every day for five years at the time
so I had that huge history of being an
athlete to begin with and then on top of
that I put the 18 months of training
specifically for this and it's the way
it would work would be I would run I
would do six-week a six-week block where
I'm where I was applying a certain
stress and so my first 6-week block
would be I was
basically just working on getting long
distance because when I was running
triathlons I only ever did you know 5k
max so I was I would run an hour I
probably run three times a week would be
an hour 90 minutes in another hour and
they'd be spaced out by a couple days so
I do six weeks of that and then I would
do a little test block and my first test
block was running the Marine Corps
Marathon again so there's one marathon
and then I do another six weeks UNK
where I would change the stress and make
it a little bit harder so I would do I
would either run a little bit longer on
my really long run for the week or I
would block them together maybe you like
run an hour and a half Wednesday and
then run an hour Thursday I kind of
change up the the blocking and after
that six weeks I would do again and I
would do two marathons and the first
time I attempted two marathons I
actually failed I did I couldn't I ran
the first one the next day I ran maybe
half marathon and I and I quit I was
like had you already said you were gonna
run thirty-one marathons yeah at this
point yeah that's reassuring yeah all
right but I kind of knew thirty one or
two like two I told my friends was like
yeah I tried to run - I didn't they were
like but like what was it what was the
failure based on I didn't need enough
the day before so the part of the reason
I was doing these tests blocks was
figuring out first of all pacing you
know good with different different ways
to pace it to make sure I didn't blow up
and then figuring out how much I needed
to eat and figuring out you know what it
was gonna feel like and so that first
time I attempted to I didn't eat enough
carbs the day you know after that first
marathon so I was just totally depleted
the next day this was like okay I didn't
it wasn't a lack of willpower or a lack
of kind of ability at that time it was
just my approach at that time wasn't
wasn't right so I was like okay I didn't
really panic about that because I knew I
kind of knew what happened and so they
all right and so I go and then I do six
and exit kind of just repeated that for
the year and a half where six
big trunk and I just change it block
them together a little bit more run
longer and then I tried three marathons
and I succeeded and it was pretty easy
I'm not easy but you know it's I was
like all right three would be he's a boy
three yeah I don't feel that bad you
know and then I did another six week I'm
changing the stress again longer and
blocked together more I rent five I was
like all right five okay
and I would mess around with the
different different pacing strategies
different ways of breaking up the mayor
each marathon taking breaks and that
kind of thing and eating different foods
just to see how all that I would react
to that and then after five I was like
you know what I'm gonna I'm not gonna do
any more than five because if I do more
than five I'm just gonna want to keep
going don't really want to so five is
enough I felt really good after five and
then after that I just kind of trained
through four maybe three more months but
I kept every six weeks I kept adding
more mileage until the last 12 weeks I
was running a marathon every Thursday
and how many total miles were you
putting in a week in that last 12 weeks
probably 60 like my my you know how they
say a deadlift starts at hundred and
thirty-five pounds you know like my runs
would start at two hours you know I
wouldn't do anything less than two hours
and then yeah I would do that marathon
on Thursday and I would run two hours
the day before in two hours the day
after and the reason I was doing that
was just get just run a marathon so many
times leading up to it that the thought
of running one marathon isn't really
this is norm it became normal to me and
so it's trying to take you of running to
run a marathon at the pace at your
sustained 31-day pace at my sustain it
was interesting so we run in like eight
minute miles nine minute miles usually
it would it would be between 8:30 and
nine minute miles and it was interesting
because in the summer time I was running
like a four and a half hour marathon of
total running time and so all the
prediction
I put on my website we like I'm probably
gonna finish about this amount of time
but I had that was during the hot and
humid summer in Virginia mm-hmm
whereas when I was doing this it was in
the fall time so I was actually able to
run faster and people would come out and
say what you said you could be running
like nine ten minute merit n minute
miles then you're running eight thirty s
or eight or nine minutes and it was kind
of it was what else was interesting was
I figured my first marathon would be I'd
be fresh and I would be my fastest
marathon and so that was in London it
was about four hours roughly of running
time with breaks I would take three
20-minute breaks four hours of running
time and then it kind of did follow that
trajectory where Philadelphia New York
and Boston were a little bit slower like
405 415 somewhere in there and then
after I got there I actually started
getting faster so the next all the way
into Chicago my fastest one might was my
tenth one in Chicago was 350 and of
running time and then after that it kind
of has leveled off and I be I'd usually
be going somewhere between 350 and 4
hours the human body is amazing yeah and
all this stuff that I've been able to
adapt to and even I still wasn't able to
predict that I would actually get faster
I didn't expect that and so that I mean
this goes to show you that the body can
adapt to even more than you think what
are the biggest challenges of regular
running and running with prosthetics on
so yeah one of the one of the things I
had to figure out was one of the things
I learned and the my first and second
Marine Corps Marathon was that I needed
to figure out how I was gonna prevent
skin breakdown right and so prevent I
would run after my first marathon I ran
and then I took my legs off and it was
this blood I like take the liner off in
his blood to shot everywhere and it
wasn't all blood but it was like kind of
blood mixed with sweat right oh my god
what'd I do to myself did I I was I was
scared I was like did I mess up my skin
graft is that thing because those things
can be kind of sense
and it ended up just being a little
blister like a little I've rubbed the
skin off and this is like the size of
that big but I knew if I did I ran again
the next day and that's guys gonna get
bigger and that's gonna totally derail
the whole thing so I had to figure out a
way that I could avoid getting like my
skin rubbing off and so I started
messing around I wear these things
called liner liners that kind of wick
the sweat they kind of collect the sweat
to help with clamminess and so usually I
put those on and they would go all the
way around the end of my stump and be
like a sock on the end so what I did was
I cut that off at the end and so it's
kind of basically like kind of like a
rash guard on my thigh and it wouldn't
go down to the end of the stump hmm so I
cut that off why do you want it to go
down to the end so what my theory was
it's kind of a cloth
it's a cloth material so what I figured
was and the the liner itself is a
silicone and I didn't figure that the
silicone would be creating a whole lot
of friction so what I figured was maybe
that little liner liner you know as
comfortable as it was was it was still
fabric so it was probably just 40,000
steps still rubbing the skin all right
so I'll cut that off and see what
happens and that was good but it still
didn't fix everything so what I ended up
doing was I just know from my cycling
experience I'd use chamois cream on my
on your butt you know to help prevent
saddle sores it's like well maybe I'll
take the chamois cream and put it on
these spots that I know tend to get rub
so I I would goop up I would just take a
huge group and just slather it on there
and and that seemed to fit that fixed it
pretty good and so I was like all right
so I figured that method out so that's
one of the things is trying to figure
with running with prosthetics is
figuring out how to avoid that skin
breakdown and that's kind of numero uno
cuz that can I mean you can be as strong
as you want but if your skin if you
can't put your leg on because the skin
hurts so much then all that strength it
does doesn't matter so so what you do
with your diet were you just pound in
calories I've been just eating
everything in sight yeah so I approached
my diet a little bit differently than
most
you might expect for marathons I did a
low-carb diet well what would be a
low-carb for this kind of thing so I was
using this and all my training and all
my pacing and all my eating I did this
thing called the MAF atone method and
it's basically this guy film a Fatone
figured that you should do all your
training at an aerobic level so he
figured out this through experience he
calculated your he's came up with an
equation to calculate your maximum
aerobic heart rate it was a 180 minus
your age and then there's other little
adjustments you can make to that so my
Moffet own heart rate was 149 and so I
never ran anything over 149 through on a
heart rate monitor all the time yeah I
had a TomTom watch and I had one that my
wife has one so I had two on when I was
running my marathon just in case one
messed up and so I ran all I'm all my
training and all my marathons were run
at as close to that 149 heart rate and
what it does is trains instead of like
making you stronger your muscles
stronger it actually trains your
cardiovascular efficiency so when you
start out you'll be running at 149
heartrate and you'll be pretty slow but
as you do that more your heart and lungs
will become more and more efficient so
eventually you'll be running at that
same 149 heart rate but you'll be
running twice as fast because it's
becoming more efficient so I just
approached it like that or I like I kind
of figured it'd be better to do it that
way because the more glycolysis and the
more carbohydrates you use the more your
body's gonna have to they're more
destructive to your body so I'm like
well in order to be able to run these I
have to run them out of maintainable
pace in a maintainable way I can't just
go out and run as fast as I can every
single one I had to pace it and so I
figured that's how I was gonna pace it
keeping my heart rate under 150 not
using those carbs and that also allowed
me to be able to eat just really high
fat I think I had between
hundred and fifty and 175 grams of carbs
a day and that's what I limited it to
and then I would eat during the run
I would eat three bonk breaker bars I
wanted each of my breaks and they're
just like these little energy bars and
that would keep me going they'll be my
kind of a lot of carbs there so that
would kind of keep me going during the
run I would just drink water whenever I
got thirsty and then after I ran
we had pre-made these me pre-made all my
meals and we just made this super
calorie dense cheese and meat sauce that
we froze we put it all in the freezer
and it was just the densest you know the
calorie dense stuff you could pause like
you know could hold containers and cream
and cheese and all this stuff so super
dense and my mom would heat up a bowl of
that for me and I would take a bag of
pork rinds and put that in the chili and
mix that in there and get the whole
thing and a lot of the times before I
even ran I would eat another bag of pork
cracklings so I'd have two bags of pork
rinds this big-ass bowl of meat sauce
and cheese sauce and then I would eat
some sweet potato chips things like that
if somebody brought us doughnuts I'd
have a doughnut you know we have issues
pork rinds good doughnuts know if people
and people could see what just happened
to Joe's I was gonna come across so I'd
eat that a minute that for dinner I'd
eat eggs and bacon and the whole time
you're you've got an RV because because
you did this in 31 different cities yeah
you started off in London and then you
flew back to America and then started
the grind New York Chicago just going
around the country yeah and you your
wife and a little support team was in
the RV yep so was four of us it was a
Pam what kind of you did you have um
coachmen mirada I think it sounds it's
like a 35 do you have RV I do 35-footer
huh yeah what's class a 35 foot
king-size bed in the back oh yeah that's
nice don't you sleep good in RVs as long
as you're not moving I don't know why I
sleep like a baby in RVs I slept well
but it's it's not totally comfortable
when you're driving down the highway at
60 yeah it's pretty bouncy back there
and there's it made it this is something
I didn't expect was I made it kind of
hard to eat being in the back I'd have
to eat all this stuff and by that being
in the back of that RV for five six
hours I would start to get a little bit
yeah he's in the back one RV is a lot
more bouncy than being in the front oh
yeah big time that's the axle there's so
much weight yeah yeah so be Pam my wife
team leader she drove some she drove a
lot any I wasn't even I wasn't really in
charge of the your day-to-day yeah my
job quiet and run yeah exactly well run
when I needed to run when I need to do
interviews run my mouth Oh No do that
and then that was it pretty much and
then put Pam she was doing everything
you know driving setting up scheduling
all my interviews working with these
reporters and like oh we want to do this
at 6:30 can we make that happen she
scheduled it in and then calling ahead
to the venues that we had decided to run
at and you know squaring that away okay
where can we park we're coming now
and there's probably so many other jobs
that I didn't even know about that she
was doing and then you know it's taken
on a boatload of stress for her and then
my mom would she'd be kind of Pam's
assistant she be in charge of kind of
keeping me fed and hydrated during when
I was running making tried to need
anything
and then afterwards she would make my
meals and then one of her most important
jobs was she's a massage therapist so
she'd give me two massages every day
after I ran while we were driving to the
next place and then I also had a driver
who who did most of the driving and then
he he just kind of helped out around the
the RV like whatever
Pam needed him to do something he would
do it what kind of people joined you on
the runs I know you said you were
telling me yesterday some some realm
in England oh yeah joined you got it out
there I mean tons of military if I had
to categorize I mean it did people beat
people from all walks of life and the
ultra runners would find out about it
and people that ran people that didn't
even run would come out a lot of
military I would say 50% of the people
though that came out I'd say I'd hear
about this they say jaakko podcast at
least 50% of them that's killer um the
troopers are not playing around ya know
they're there to support do a major
support and then yes it'd be a lot of
Millett a lot of guys that I deployed
with came out and supported a lot of
cops a lot of fire departments but you
know it's it there really wasn't one
niche it was just even kids would come
out yeah kids would come out people with
their parents a full families would come
out for the day and and run it was also
my kids that ran their first ever
marathon with with me awesome and a lot
of people would just they be running
their first marathon and then I had a
white lady she's like well I'm running a
marathon next week but I'm gonna run one
with you and she PB you know and so it'd
be all sorts of people I'd come out of
the RV in the morning and there just be
people that have been waiting there for
me to come out and no matter what and it
didn't matter time in the morning would
you start running I would usually start
around 7:00
unless I had some kind of big interview
like I had a Fox and Friends interview
when I was in New York so I started at
7:30 or 8:00 but I would try and be
pretty religious about starting at 7:00
and then people be out there didn't
matter if it was 20 degrees in Denver
they'd be out there if it was raining
they'd be out there you know it was
awesome
that is awesome what was the what was
the hardest part or did you meet any
hard parts during the during the trip
was there any and actually I remember
when you were getting ready to go yeah
this is pretty cool I'm like hey man
like what if you know what if you're not
gonna make it like what if you can you
know and what I was actually thinking
about I was thinking about your legs and
yeah
know that I mean I've you know I've got
other friends that have prosthetics and
I know that it's a that it's a grind and
it rips your skin apart and I was kind
of thinking that's what I was thinking I
wasn't thinking like oh you orgas gonna
get tired and quit but I was thinking
that there there might come a point
where you physically weren't gonna be
able to do this without you know causing
a massive damage to your body and and
possibly you know getting infections and
everything else and I said you know what
if you know what if something happens
and you were like no I'm gonna okay well
there you have it well you know that was
something I was concerned about - I
didn't know how my body was gonna react
to it and I didn't know for sure I never
knew even up to the last one the last
mile the last one I'd I would never say
I'm definitely gonna finish this because
you know anything can happen I could
have my prosthetic on twisted a little
bit and then that rubs off skin on my
skin graft and then that causes it to
die or something then I'm screwed then I
have I can't you know I can't continue
so I never knew for sure but I
I believed that as long as everything
kind of went according to plan then it
was possible as long as no catastrophic
events happen and I was feeling
confident I was very confident the whole
time and then I got all the way around
to Texas and I had been really lucky
with the weather all the way around we
get to Texas and we're hitting a heat
wave in Texas and and it was probably I
woke up in the morning in uh Houston
sweating alright just sweating already
it's ridiculous I was just covered in
sweat waking up in Houston it was like a
hundred percent humidity probably like
75 80 degrees just to start the day
Houston get some oh my god and the heat
gets to me pretty easily it's it's the
one thing that could really slow me down
but I came out of that RV and there were
and the heat that he can get to you
because you you basically are missing a
couple radiators oh yeah I mean because
your body
everyone's body gives off a lot of heat
their legs and you don't have those
radiators to give off heat anymore so
you you can overheat fairly quickly
exactly yeah and then my let my so in
addition not having the radiators my
legs are encased in carbon fiber so it's
actually bottling in the heat on my legs
instead so I can really slow me down but
I came out of that RV and Houston and
there was just 70 people there waiting
for me to run and a lot of more Marines
there's a local Marine recruiting office
that came out and they brought their
pool these people that were about to go
to boot camp awesome and they brought
him out and I'm like well it doesn't
matter you know I I'm gonna I'm gonna
even if they weren't there I still would
have been a ran here but I'm like man
look at all these people that want to
run with me and so I just did it and
then it just it took a long I think that
was quite my long is it was probably
four and a half hours of running and
there was a guy in his regular
wheelchair that did it with me the whole
time just rollin in his wheelchair by me
so that was a really tough date so the
San Antonio Houston Dallas were all
really hot really humid and I had to him
back to back to back but I got through
it because people came out and ran with
me and I kept me going and then in
Nashville I it was it had been raining
that day and I was running on a trail
and there were these wooden bridges over
these little rip creeks and I had run on
wooden British before so I knew they
were gonna be slippery and I was like oh
I'm gonna take it slow over this and I
still I slipped on this bridge and
injured my back not at the time it
didn't feel like a hundred at the time I
was like mmm was kind of a hard fall and
I kept running the next day when I woke
up in Atlanta my back was killing me and
I had four left and I just had to gut it
out you know every time I landed on my
right foot it was like kind of shot a
bad pain into my into my middle back and
it was a little bit frustrating because
I was like I was feeling so good up to
that point
and I had run a super-fast marathon in
Memphis I was feeling so good I was like
oh man I'm gonna be able to really enjoy
these last four you know and then you
know the universe is like nope gonna
have to earn it
gonna have to earn it it would cruise
these last four and then you finished up
on Veterans Day yeah in in DC in DC
Veterans Day my back was feeling a
little bit better at this point but
still hurting pretty bad and was
interesting because all up to that point
my my stumps were feeling pretty good
they had I I started to get these little
pockets of fluid on that kind of the
outer corner of both of them and they
hurt when I pushed on them and then
usually for the first mile they would
hurt pretty bad and he got to where my
mom had this like kind of icy hot spray
she was spraying that on on the ends
every day to help and so but after the
first mile that pain would kind of go
away I would just pound them into
submission or whatever and they would be
like all right you're gonna keep going
we're just gonna turn ourselves off or
whatever and so after the first mile I'd
be good and they wouldn't really hurt it
much more until it bosses a knuckle head
and yeah so after the first mile would
be they'd be fine but on that last day
in Washington DC they just never turned
off and I think maybe it was because
there's that same thing where I knew
this was the last one and my body kind
of knew it was the last one
so was starting to maybe let itself it
had held on to that last one and maybe
was starting to let itself unravel a
little bit so that whole last day was
just pain in the back freezing cold it
was like 20 degrees out and so every
time I stopped to rest I was sweating I
was like you know I had a hot water
bottle I was all snuggled up with under
a blanket and I would still be like cold
but just the sheer number of people that
were there I'd never what I there was
never less than a hundred people running
with me that an entire day it's awesome
and I had there was people there that
had run with me in other cities that
came and came for the last one I had
brothers with me that had deployed to
Afghanistan all they're running with me
I had for my last mile I had there was a
general running he was out in front so
we're running around the National Mall
my last mile all around the reflecting
pools it's about a mile and so there was
a general out front the way you know and
then there was a sergeant major who had
been my company first sergeant with them
so they were running like side-by-side
like politely telling people to get out
of the way sergeant major Kent
retired a sergeant major of the Marine
Corps top sergeant major in the Marine
Corps was running with me that last
maybe 12 K singing cases there was a you
know I just had I had brothers with me
that were in the group their kids you
know Pam joined me for that last mile my
mom joined me I had family in there for
the last mile and before we started that
last mile like gear I prom it was like
alright everybody I'm gonna take this
last mile real slow just so we can
everybody can stay together and then by
the end of them I was like sprinting
with so pumped up you know to be
finished but man it was so cool and I
finished that last little loop and I
kind of like ran up there's this little
curved sidewalk that goes up to the
Lincoln Memorial and so I finished that
last mile and I kind of curve it up to
that last and the whole sidewalk was
lined with folks and then they had set
up a little finish line for me up there
and the whole thing was just line with
people like yeah you know and cross the
finish line
Pam was there you know we celebrated she
cried I did not cry make that clear
right now finished you know kissed her
hugged her and then the
the reporters kind of came in and
started a talking awesome and you ready
raise money yeah you raise money a bunch
of money for yeah I know you support a
bunch of foundations so that was awesome
too you know it was sort of the other
driving force behind you doing it
besides this you're crazy but also you
were raising money for a bunch of good
causes yeah you know raising money we
raised two hundred thousand at the time
I finished I I kind of I stopped keeping
track but it's probably like two hundred
fifteen now or something like that for
number five fun tunnel to towers
foundation coalition to suit America's
Heroes and that was kind of that was
that was kind of how I almost manifested
physically manifested how successful
that was so my what I was trying to do
is this create that's create a story
that people could feed off of and so
when you when you look at all the
stories that are out there about
veterans coming back the vast vast vast
vast majority of stories are the
post-traumatic stress story every movie
that comes out that is about of Oh F oh
we have veteran coming home is that's
pretty much the same same recipe veteran
goes overseas they experience war they
see some bad stuff like you do in war
they come back and they're a basket case
and they implode and they implode their
family and all this stuff and that's
again that's a hugely important story to
note because it does happen and it's we
have to take care of those guys and we
have to make sure we keep that story in
our in the forefront of our minds but
what started to bother me was that was
the only story that was getting told and
I think general mattis said it best when
he answered the question somewhere and
he said you know expectations are very
strong so if you if you go overseas and
everybody's kind of expecting you to
basically have pts
then there's a good chance that you're
gonna manifest that in yourself just by
Duke by virtue of the fact that that's
what's expected and so you're just gonna
create that yeah and so what I wanted to
do was get this story out there tell a
story where there was a guy that went
overseas had a traumatic experience and
came back and was better than he was
before and so that was how I determined
I was gonna create this story and you
know I felt that I knew that this was a
problem that this story wasn't getting
out there and no so I felt the
responsibility to create it myself you
know if it's not out there it's like
what I was saying that I can't journal
you know I had that responsibility
because it just wasn't out there very
much and so I set out to create that
story and then you know so if if there
was a guy that was struggling he could
see that story and then he could see you
know what it actually is possible to go
see war and come back and be fine and or
not be necessarily be totally fine but
overcome it and find your new path and
find your new mission and continue on
keep fighting for veterans keep fighting
for your brothers and if they've that
there's a guy that's coming home and
he's kind of on the fence he sees that
story and maybe take some the the right
way and then at the same time getting it
out there for civilians there's a major
military civilian gap of understanding
because military tends to be isolated
and on the bases and you know that the I
could see that gap because of all these
movies that were coming out there's
every like a hundred percent of movies
that came out were the main character at
PTSD whereas you look at the statistics
and it's 25% of non-combat troops have
what we'll call PTSD 7% of combat troops
have PTSD and so it's a huge
misrepresentation of the actual of the
actual scale and so I wanted civilians
to see that story but here here's a
veteran that came came home and was
you know he was able to kind of adapt
her process what he'd seen no I think
that's a hundred percent right I think
you get you get you nailed it and
Madison ailed it yeah like you set the
expectations that everyone thinks that
when they go to war they're gonna be all
screwed up it's like that's what's gonna
happen to him but if they if they get
told hey and and I mean you know you
just said when you came home you were
better yeah and like that's awesome and
you know I had that conversation with
Sam Harris where you know I he'd asked
me he said hey you know you you get told
you hear you saying that war is horrible
and war is hell but at the same time you
say that it was like the best highlight
of your life and it was and I told him
and he's like how do you reconcile those
two things and I said well have you ever
known someone that had cancer and when
they get if they make it through they
say it made him a better person and they
wouldn't wish it on anyone but it made
him a better person and and he said yeah
and it made sense to him then yeah and
and that's what I think is an important
thing and you know look at the I mean
every war has incredible veterans that
come home and do incredible things and I
mean Charlie plum when he was on you
know after being in the Hanoi Hilton for
six years and he rattled off the the
guys that were in the Hanoi Hilton with
him yeah that were you know presidents
and and congressmen and just did all
these incredible achievements maybe not
presidents but incredible incredible
achievements while presidential
candidate Stockdale so and Ann McCain
write to presidential candidates so so
incredible achievements and yet the the
media and the Hollywood they don't shine
the light on that what they shine the
light on is the the the the people that
are having issues which again like you
said that's real - yeah but the fact
that you made this huge effort and are
continuing to make a huge effort to show
not just civilians but also military
that yeah war is bad I mean you've you
know you say you had a traumatic
experience you had a frickin
life-changing experience and you've come
back and you've you've proven
that that traumatic experience is not as
strong as you are and I think that's the
most important message that that anyone
could communicate back to both sides
both the civilian and military side yeah
and I mean there's so much to be said
about what knowing something is already
possible so I told you about Dan
Connaughton last time I was here and
back then he was about a year and a half
in front of me yeah and he was showing
me what was possible for me I didn't
know that it was possible to be able to
walk around and with a huge backpack on
and using no canes but once I saw it
it's like wow so it is fallen it just
made it so much easier to do and I was
doing a talk not too long ago and
somebody told me afterwards that
something that I didn't even realize I
was you know how last time I was talking
about finding IDs and that we do that
thing called proof the lane yeah
and they told me that that they just
kind of mentioned to me that I kind of
had continued I did that in the Marine
Corps and I did this thing called
proofing the lane where I was proving
what what I was you know stepping on the
ground and proving was cleared and then
they said that kind of that I didn't
realize that there's a time but they
said that theme is following you
wherever you go so I'm I'm now
proofing the lane for these these
veterans that may be struggling a little
bit so I'm trying to improving what's
possible and so yeah I'm glad that they
glad they told me that cuz that really
makes that makes total sense and Dan
Connaughton who's a total stud but be in
a parallel again yeah Young was it young
yep Chang yeah
South Korea - I think he's doing
biathlon and cross-country skiing yeah
no he's a total beast seal that also
lost both his legs above the knee and
just a total badass stud I want to read
a couple more little sections from your
journal to close this out here we go
back to the journals so when I get asked
by people how could
you fathom let alone complete running
thirty-one marathons in 31 days I give
them the same simple answer because I am
a room a marine and my mission to fight
for my fellow veterans has not changed
and when a marine is on mission for his
fellow Marines he is capable of anything
therefore when people asked me haven't
you done enough sacrificed enough I
remind them that not only do I have the
capability to accomplish my mission be
proud of my marine corps heritage stay
faithful to my fellow Marines and keep
fighting I have the responsibility I
have the responsibility to keep fighting
for my country my core and my fellow
veterans so no it will never be enough
the day that I have done enough will be
the day that six Marines lower my body
into my grave in Arlington Cemetery and
how can I do it I do it because it is my
duty and to do my duty is my honor in
one last little passage I want to read
from your journal it says I am merely a
representative of what is possible for
any veteran any person so as time passes
I do not want my name to be remembered
all I want to be remembered is the story
years from now when people speak about
this I want him to say I remember that
guy who ran all those marathons that one
time and their friend will will reply
what was his name then they will say I
don't remember but he was a Marine
well Rob I can tell you that I got a
feeling that you will be remembered and
your name will be remembered and the way
that you have represented the Marines
and America and mankind will be
remembered and remembered and revered as
well so thanks for coming on the show
again and letting us all know that we
are capable of much much more if we just
step up and push a little bit harder
been awesome having you back on man
it's been awesome being here I mean
again I'm glad I could come up with the
material once you say you've invited me
back I was like I got our start writing
some stuff no you don't have to write
just want to talk
echo he got me questions for the man
yeah was there any time like during the
31 marathons that you were like all this
kind of lame well yeah did you ever
think that I mean not even necessarily
that you were like tired physically or
nothing just kind of like you know
that's interesting I got I definitely
got tired of doing the interviews okay
yeah yeah but the thing with that is the
interviews you know I didn't I wasn't
doing this to like to get a bunch of you
know people telling me I'm awesome you
know anything but the interviews so
doing the the marathons without the
interviews would be pointless
mm-hm because the story wouldn't get out
there without interviews but doing the
interviews without the story without
doing the marathons is actually it's all
so pointless
kind of got the funny thing is I did
this because it was gonna be hard I did
this because gonna be really difficult
yeah
and I knew that going in and that's the
whole purpose of it was do something
that was hard and then you know the last
four days and in Houston and stuff when
it started to get hard I was like it's
bullshit
was it so hard but yeah I'd like I said
I was saying before there was never a
point where I was like there's no way I
can do this
mm-hmm or anything like that I was like
as long as I don't get severely injured
by a mistake don't get hit by a car or
you'll break a bone or something then
I'm gonna be able to do this yeah gonna
get her done yeah I feel like they're
like everyone's wrong when I do
something that takes a long time like
months or something like that I get to a
point everyone every once in a while
yeah I mean it gets repetitive for sure
yeah yeah
wake up run you know what's good music
you don't listen to do this in a podcast
do you listen to music didn't really on
the month of marathons except a few
times because with Utah I had people
with me they're just gonna be like hey
I'm listening to a podcast leave me
alone sometimes I do that there were
times I did do that sometimes that too
that Wednesday morning that Jaakko
podcast you're hoping for a long word
one of the few people I was hoping for a
four-hour podcast there worked there I
felt kind of bad in the last four
because I told you my back was hurting
so much and I was like every time I
landed on that right foot of eve's
severe pain and then I kind of make me I
kind of gasp a little bit yeah and so I
felt really bad because there's a lot of
people that were you know they came out
to run with me and they were like
talking to me and trying to trying to
help me keep going but I just was not in
the mood for talking you know and I felt
terrible because they like ask me
questions I'd be that giving them the
one word you know like oh you know they
but what's your favorite place or
whatever I'm like I don't know like and
so I wish I could have handled that part
a little bit better and you know getting
let those people you know talk to those
people but I'm sure they understand
they're why and I kind of said it before
they listen everybody if I'm not talking
if it's cuz I have this back injury it's
not because I don't like yes because I
hate you
yes as that but you know when when it
got hard I fell back on on my mission
and that's what that's what I was doing
it for it didn't whether or not I was
hurting or didn't feel like doing it was
not as important it doesn't have
anything to do with anything really does
does not vary can I ask your I want to
ask your opinion on something because I
came up with a theory and it's not
totally thought out yet and like my and
this theory might actually get me killed
so please echo defended me I think that
there may be something that's more
powerful than discipline and anybody
that's listening Jocko reach for the
knife and and maybe it's just that
they're kind of go hand in hand but I
think the one thing that maybe as
powerful or maybe even more powerful in
the discipline is selflessness and so
the reason I say that is because I don't
know maybe the discipline leads to the
ability to perform the selfless acts but
it seems to me like all the discipline
in the world might not allow you to do
something like lift a car off of your
child you know are or dive on a grenade
well yeah I mean there's I think you're
actually 100 percent right okay that's a
theory I think that you know when you
take guys in combat when when guys are
in combat and guys do incredible things
and sacrifice their lives for their
brothers that that is not about
discipline and did you know they're
doing that because they're selfless and
they want to take care of their friends
that's what they're doing it for yeah
and and you know there can be people
that are you know undisciplined
individuals that perform incredibly
heroic things in combat so no I don't
think I don't think it's a I don't think
it's I think that's actually correct I
mean I think there's that's a extremely
powerful force and I've you know that
maybe
that and and I was thinking about you
know the the power of that I thought you
were gonna say what I thought you were
gonna talk about it was you know you
weren't doing this for yourself you know
you weren't doing this for yourself you
were doing this to get a message out
there that you're doing this that to
raise money for others for your friends
for your brothers that's that is a more
powerful thing than hey I'm just a self
discipline person now you know
discipline is like an it's like they're
it's like they're they're indifferent
it's not apples to apples I don't think
it's not like it's not like this is more
powerful than that no because I'll tell
you that if you want to perform well if
you want to achieve things like you
wouldn't be able to do this for these
causes if you didn't have the discipline
to train hard to eat right to get on the
path to stay on the path you wouldn't be
able to do this even though you really
wanted to even though you really really
wanted to you really really wanted to
care about your brothers you really
really wanted to raise money for those
funds if you have the discipline to make
it happen and and train yourself and be
ready that that you wouldn't be able to
deliver that just like a guy on the
battlefield there on the battlefield
because they they were able to perform
they were able to have the discipline to
get to that point but they're there to
I'd say they're related I don't think
they're they're definitely not opposing
each other and I and in fact I think
that if I was to tell you you know when
I was in the SEAL Teams what the DRA the
actual driving force behind the
discipline that that I tried to have
myself wasn't for me it was like I want
to be able to perform well on the
battlefield not because I want to
perform well but because I want to make
sure I don't let my brother's down yeah
so I would say it's actually like a
force that's a foundational force you
know it's like people that are heavily
heavily religious their discipline
relies on their religious faith people
that are overachievers that want to
accomplish something their discipline is
based on the fact that they want to get
that achievement so the discipline by
itself there has to be something that
the discipline there has to be a
foundation that that's built upon and I
think a lot of times people
build their their foundation of
discipline the foundation that their
discipline is built on is actually the
fact that they want to take care of
their friends they want to be able to
take care of their brothers I want to
take care of their family you know you
get all kinds of you know I was you take
a single mom that's working three jobs
right now well she has to be highly
disciplined she has to be highly
disciplined she's got to get up every
morning at 3 o'clock to get to the diner
in time to start waiting tables she's
doing that she has that discipline not
based on the fact that she wants to be
stronger for herself she's doing that so
she can feed her kids she's doing that
she's doing that selflessly so that she
can feed her kids yeah so no I mean
that's a that's absolutely true and I
totally agree warding yeah supporting uh
yeah I think the the best way the way to
get the most out of yourself as a figure
out a way to make it about something
that you care about more than yourself
yeah yeah I mean I think that discipline
is a manifestation of of selflessness in
many ways it's a way that you're like I
said a single mom that's working three
jobs look let's face it she doesn't want
to work any of those three jobs she
doesn't want to work any of those three
jobs but she's doing it she's doing it
every day day in day out why is she
doing that she why does she just
measuring that discipline and
manifesting that discipline it's because
she cares about her kids more than she
cares about herself and that's all there
is to it and you could go to the
battlefield and say the same thing why
do you why do why do Marines train so
hard yeah why why do we train hard the
SEAL Teams what why are we doing that
are we doing that for ourselves are we
imposing that discipline on ourselves
are we having the self discipline
because we want to be good for ourselves
no it's because we want to be able to
take care of our friends we want to be
able to take care of our brothers and
and you could go across the board with
any of that so I totally agree with you
but could they
at any point come into conflict with
each other
where you got to choose to remain
disciplined or serve others I don't I
don't see how they would come in
conflict with each other and if they did
come in conflict I think you make a
rational decision yeah you know like I
mean I mean
hey am I gonna get sneaked my workout in
like what's more important to me working
out or or going on a mission with my
friends right right or your I don't know
daughter's piano recital that they want
you to be at but you got it you know
that it's got what you got to choose you
choose between one one being disciplined
with the workout that day okay I'm
making the recital I mean obviously you
want to make the recital but if the
thief the choice is between making the
recital and you have to go to your job
and work well if you don't go to your
job and work that's what now you don't
have money to pay for your piano lessons
in the first place yeah think about that
that's all I'm saying is that this is
where a situation where discipline and
selflessness will come into conflict
I'm just saying usually they're they
support each other and for sure I think
us but is there a circumstance yes
there's there's there's you could
actually become you could actually focus
on yourself and be like hey it's more
important for me to take care of me
right then it is for me to take care of
my team and that's not gonna go over
well with the team and we may end up
being you know a highly disciplined
individual you you have no you you have
no outlet for because you have no one to
take care of a few except for yourself
and that's what you see like though
what's what's the I haven't watched the
movie but I know exactly no I'm serious
I haven't watched the movie it's
American Psycho right oh no I haven't
watched the movie but but I I know
exactly what the story is the guy is
like super highly disciplined right yeah
that's the way he does everything highly
disciplined yeah but at the same time
obviously he's a psycho and he's he's
not supporting anyone but himself
sure so that's like an extreme version
of someone that cares about themselves
yeah they sure they're highly
disciplined but you know being highly
disciplined doesn't make you a good
person yeah it doesn't automatically
make you self well yeah it doesn't make
you selfless and it certainly doesn't
make you a good person either and you
could certainly get into a situation
where you know you get people that are
bank robbers know a highly disciplined
bank robber I wasn't thinking bake
robbers but you think you know the
people that are so into working out that
that trumps yeah you family and
everything trumps everything
yeah and they and they have an issue
right
there's so into it that they did they
sacrifice not even sacrifice they just
don't care yeah yeah it's uh what you
know when you meet someone that's so
into working out that I mean that's a
very selfish thing right working out as
a selfish thing right you know there's
part of it that's selfless because
you're working out so that you can stay
healthy so you can take care of your
family you can take care of friends like
we just talked about you can take that
to a point yeah so you're capable of
surviving and taking care of your your
friends your family but you can easily
get to a point where hey the most
important thing is me yeah my pull-up
the most important thing is me and my
numbers yeah my numbers and you know
what I was danger close to this with
jujitsu because for a while I was like
yeah I'd come home at night and my and
my wife would be like you know this is I
was still in the teams yeah and I was
was a tasking to commander like we I was
that that was the most important thing
in my life but I would still come home
at night at 7:30 at night or eight
o'clock at night and I'd grab my gym bag
and I'd go train jujitsu and my wife
would be like what the hell is wrong
with you
yeah like what are you doing and that's
that was borderline right that was
borderline but for me it was like hey
this is a skill set that I should have
when I'm on the battlefield so I can
take care of myself to take care of my
friends and by the way that means I have
a one point zero zero one percent chance
that I'm gonna come home instead of not
come home so I'm gonna do it and that
eat right there that's probably a little
bit of rut rationalization cuz cuz cuz
selfishly I really love training
jiu-jitsu yes so there's there's a
selfishness there and I that I just
tried to rationalize a little bit and
and you know that we talked we talked
about the first podcast with you is
rationalization and how you've got to be
careful of that gotta be careful of
rational rationalizing everything yeah
so yeah those are those are things that
definitely can get can become can become
problematic effusion if well that's what
you know what that's why there's a
dichotomy that's why there's a dichotomy
and everything cuz you can go overboard
with any any personality trait you can
go too far with yeah and you can
definitely go that that's why I
discipline and freedom it's it's
actually a
you know discipline equals freedom but
guess what if you have pure discipline
if you if you remove all freedom well
then what did you just do
enslave yours yeah you enslaved so you
there's balance there's balance in in
discipline there has to be balanced
discipline I think the reason that it
strikes people to talk about discipline
equals freedom is because most people
don't make that connection and most
people lean so far towards just freedom
of doing whatever they want that they
end up enslaved from a different
direction yeah which is equally if not
more problematic and I say more
problematic cuz now you end up in a
situation where you're slaved you're
enslaved by something that's not good
that's not healthy that's not positive
whereas at least with discipline if
you're imposing the discipline on
yourself self-discipline well then
you're you're imposing things on you
that are at least positive long term and
at a minimum they're positive long term
yeah now can you go overboard of that
yes there's people that have eating
disorders right oh yeah there's people
out of eating disorders they they impose
such strict discipline that they're
unhealthy yeah and that's bad and that's
horrible
you know I've I've heard back from some
people that that said hey you know I
have trouble with eating source you know
it's generally been females who have
more trouble with that category and they
actually have to use the discipline to
say the correct discipline thing to do
is to eat more is to eat the proper
amount of calories because it's a
horrible horrible thing if you see
people going through that and it's a
fatal disease right it's a fatal disease
and so so again to your point there's
you can become so disciplined that it's
that it's negative yeah it's negative on
your personal health it's negative on
your you know you can work yourself you
can work yourself so hard you can say
I'm gonna be disciplined at work and now
you you stop you lose the balance and
you start stop working out and you stop
training you start eating doughnuts and
you start eating doughnuts not before
you look run a marathon but before you
sit down in your front of your computer
yeah so they're there absolutely has to
be balanced but factually
the the tendency the the tendency is I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be less disciplined
and I'm gonna do things that are easy
man the easy path and that leads to
that's that's the 80% 90% I'm the 1% but
that is a vast majority of people vast
majority of people don't need less
discipline in their lives
they need more discipline that's the
vast majority people myself included
myself include need more discipline not
less yeah it's almost about what you're
being disciplined towards so like in the
the situation you bring up with a
recital
you have the competing thing so maybe it
actually takes more discipline to forego
your workout oh yeah people will say to
me like on on Twitter they'll say if you
have real discipline once you have the
discipline to sleep in tomorrow to get
out of your comfort zone and sleep in
but yes so you'd have to look at the
bigger but is there a bigger discipline
then right because you gotta you got to
consider your goals and stuff like that
right you can't have the discipline to
sleep in if that doesn't benefit your
goal right it's not even this way yeah
I'm like the person that's struggling
with the eating disorder they're
disciplined at first they were
disciplined to lose weight yeah they
need to change that discipline to be a
healthy right
consider the goal yeah the goal the goal
needs to be held at all yeah what a
scary thing or a scary thing you look in
the mirror and you you you you think
you're overweight and you're not some
guys get that the opposite for sure body
body body dysmorphia or is that what
it's called yeah so you can have it like
you know you think you're always you
always think you're fat but you're
skinny and then the other way is like
you always think you're skinny so you
need bigger muscles so you know so you
get on the juice yeah whatever
yeah asteroids that's actually why we
started cutting weight
check speaking of health and support and
support echo Charles is there any way
that you could advise us how to support
ourselves ourselves encounter and
possibly we just support you support
yeah we support you there
we support you too we did actually one
of the benefits of having you want as
your very supportive very encouraging
you know like that but in the event of
people us wanting to support this
podcast in addition to each other in
addition to ourselves or all at once we
can stay on Jaco super krill oil if I
going to say the path well yeah the path
that's bigger picture for sure and we'll
talk about that but one of the methods
to stay on the path is krill oil you can
lift a lot of weight to get strong
muscles kind of like um like when you
tear your skin apart I guess but if your
joints are all jacked up they don't know
you're not lifting nothing so and this
goes for everyday life so super krill
oil Gillette supplements finally super
crude oil joint warfare and discipline
which is a pre mission what he cognitive
enhancer force multiplier technically
what is force multiplier mean it's like
when you get one thing and another and
if the sum is worth more than the in the
parts kind of yes yeah you were so
excited about that I'm just gonna let it
roll anyway three supplements right not
counting the new one that's gonna come
out soon so krill oil for your joints
joint where for warfare for your joints
and discipline pre-mission
you take a cognitive enhancers a little
bit of caffeine in there 50 milligrams
15 milligram unless you drink multiple
scoops sure then a third I did an event
the other night
and I was kind of tired going into it
straight up I was kind of tired and
usually my events are during the day but
this is at night as I was kind of like
you know I'd flown out there and I was
feeling a little bit sight so I drank
some discipline and then I drank some
more discipline and I ended up having
I guess there's a total sum total of
about five scoops of discipline sir
so 60 milligrams but it's not just the
ballot yeah it but anyways I got done
with the event and went up to me you
know hung out with everyone for a little
bit add the little dinner thing and then
got done with that and then hung out and
then went up to my room hotel room and I
just sat there and the funny thing is I
didn't realize I was why cuz I had
gotten up early the morning worked out
to travel the bubble and I didn't
realize why am i why do I have energy
right now why can't I sleep right now
this is ridiculous what's wrong with me
what's wrong with me what's wrong with
me what's wrong with me and him then and
then I didn't realize until the next day
cuz I went to bed at 1:30 in the morning
woke up at 4:30 and then I did like a
stretch came home jack steel when I got
home of course yeah I got home did
squash but which is nice because I
always been jacked up so I haven't been
able to do I still am not doing overhead
squats right now or even front squats
alright so I am doing front squats with
kettle bell yeah and someone let's have
a bigger kettle bell than other people
but whatever sir-sir
you got to be careful don't have that if
you're not used to caffeine because I'm
not used to caffeine because I only have
chocolaty which has the same 15
milligrams or discipline if you're not
used to caffeine that little 15
milligrams and you drink a bunch of it
you're gonna feel it don't drink it
before you go to bed at night yeah
that's my warning unless you have stuff
to do unless you get stuff did yeah yeah
get after it
yeah yeah you want to balance the
discipline for sure yeah you will not
you feel sharp that's what's good about
it you feel sharp it's fun physically
and mentally when you or when someone
says hey I'm drinking the disappear for
watch Spaceballs baseball when he's like
liquid Schwartz you remember it's like
the shorts is this before Sun harity
here so instead of the force it's the
shorts right just go do the shorts and
then he had the liquid Schwartz oh yeah
so I was like the module or side for
gays
anyway that's how you sound when you say
I'm drinking the discipline you can't
drink that you know I'm saying yeah I
think you meant to do that
nonetheless you get this at origin main
dot-com
on the top it says labs actually got it
emailed me it was like hey I can't find
the dude I can't find the discipline I
said look within yourself man I said
good or domain.com on the top it says
labs but it's made of fun like that you
know jumping back and forth anyway
that's where you get ordained man calm
I'm also an organ man calm they got some
cool geese all made in America rash
guards compression gear tops and bottoms
rash guards spats spats yeah do they
have the black out yet yeah I don't have
they do you know also look at the start
planning your schedule for the origin
jujitsu camp emerge immersion camp yeah
it's not like not like a hard core like
that's the thing and that's what Pete
kind of what world is what he was kind
of telling me where it's not like the
kind it's not like like boot camp or
something which would be cool too it's
not like a training camp for like an
event no I'm saying like you know one
guy's trainer trainee yeah yeah we're
training retraining hard but it's more
like you're in there to immerse yourself
in jiu-jitsu you want to train hard you
train hard you want to learn art yeah
well yeah the case in point there's a
lot of people that have never even
trained yeah yeah yeah literally have
never trained before yeah got up said a
before this morning's class I need to
get Aggie yeah have Aggie you know so
yeah that's in August you can check on
the website for that to come on up Ecco
Charles and I will be there you want to
go yeah okay cool come on it's like this
cool yeah you can start learning more
than I taught you last time we did you
did sir yeah I have jujitsu legs now oh
you do know what about what do they look
like it's too late because I told you
got to get rid of like the hard thing
yeah they were just hard sockets right
and so what I did was you know I had I
had trouble standing up yeah so what I
did was I had these two I have the
sockets that go of my legs
so what I had my process do its cover
them in foam and then so that's a little
bit softer for people so I don't hurt
anybody
and then he made it so I could just
stand on the ends of those sockets look
the same height yes so that the same
height awesome and so now that's a
game-changer I use them to you uh I
haven't started taking jiu-jitsu because
I've been really busy but I'm gonna I
think once we get back my wife and I are
gonna start going in awesome and then I
also use them to do some weight lifting
stuff I've been able to I go how to do
squats all the way around squats yeah so
it's awesome so I'll be ready yeah no
that is awesome yeah yeah because the
biggest concern I had last time was the
the shell had like a like ax and the
metal thing yeah valve and that thing
was uncool I didn't realize at the time
that you were insulting me because
that's how I do until after is the whole
time you were after we're old you're
like oh yeah you're really strong really
strong and then later a couple podcast
later you're like oh it's actually an
insult yeah yeah you don't have any
technique but you're strong you know
that's how I learned that was almost
optimistic to a fault was that when
we're all you've talked about this
before when we roll I was like there's
gotta be a way that I can catch Jaco
there'll be some way and that guy like
who was the guy that's missing his hand
that we rolled with I rolled with after
Jeffrey
yeah Jeffrey I had him in I had him by
the neck and I was like oh and then
afterwards like there's no possible way
somehow is it so optimistic about what I
can do to a fault is that and you're the
you're with so many people yeah majority
people especially ninjutsu is it fall in
that category of work well and the other
funny thing is you'll get somebody with
something and then they think to
themselves if I can if I just stop that
yeah then I'll be able to win yeah I had
a I had a wrestler this was back in the
day I was like a booty belt and
and this blue belt and I was just going
to get this wrestler you know like a
really good college wrestler and the
look on his face every single time was
just okay let's let's go let's go again
he was the first person that I realized
that that that's the normal reaction but
especially for a wrestler because
wrestler that wrestled in college man
they've been dominating people in high
school they've been dominating people in
college they know they they understand
grappling and so when they get they get
like yeah submitted they just can't they
just don't even understand it it seems
like the one before and you know and
then and I don't know you can you can
you can give me some advice on this is
it better because I've done it both ways
is it better to submit them with the
same thing every single time which I've
done that or to submit them somewhere
something new every single time when
they just are dumbfounded yeah I think
the second one is actually giving what
you said yeah it's true the wrestler
he's gonna have all this knowledge of
grappling yeah so and it makes sense you
know so you see this one weird thing
that you never seen in your mind you're
like alright that's weird kind of rare
kind of thing it's a feeling and then
but if you're like this thing this thing
this thing it's like okay this world is
not okay I understand wasn't a fluke yes
it wasn't just that one thing like I
used to that one thing I just got to
stay away from his or yeah putting my
neck in that song so it kind of depends
deviated from that whole idea so we'll
be having these discussions and many
more at the immersion camp in Maine in
August yes right before school starts
yeah so yeah that's a good fun yeah
anyway yeah or gin main comm check it
out good way to support also jockle
talked about his new cool kettle bell
that's heavier than mine nonetheless I
got the whole set alright you know the
other ones I'm not Maria or the the
primal Bell key ones or whatever
really nothing dudes like a cyclops in
there
- anyway anymore word on the Jocko head
or still working part we're the idea
phase on that still but yeah that's good
but nonetheless you want the whole set
go to on it calm slash chuckle really
good kettlebells in there other exercise
stuff on there too you don't switch up
your worked out I ran into that the
other day like dang this workout is
getting boring it's let just btf through
it yeah and then did you because it's
good to to do things and you brought
this up before if you're not used to
something even though it's like we
talked about squats like going all the
way down what I'm used to if I was to do
squats to what is parallel to the deck
defenders yeah the standard and then
those squats would actually be a little
bit harder for me yeah for like a week
or two weeks and then I'd realize it
going down in the hole is the place yeah
yeah but and it goes along with exactly
what you're saying how like your brain
has did it's called neuromuscular
connection where if you're used to doing
a certain motion you can do it way more
efficiently put more weight on there
we're pretty efficient you know and
that's what what gain we're gains come
from yeah or a big part of where it
gains come from um so yeah he just you
just changed the movement just a little
bit boom whole nother thing your body
gotta get used to more gains to be had
well that's the whole theory of Westside
barbells and they change their the way
they do something every three weeks
they'd either yeah instead of doing this
benchpress the same exact way and they
did that for three weeks and then the
next three weeks they do it why do they
do it with a different kind of bar they
do it different range of motion mmm so
once you they don't allow their by to
totally adapt yeah I'm constantly
changing and yeah yeah that's pretty
there's a lot of cool ways you can kind
of manipulate that from workout to
workout oh yeah well that's so yeah if
you want to vary up your workout with
all kinds of different movements on it
they have some cool stuff battle maces
or no battle ropes maces some other
stuff on it comm slash chuckle good spot
also when you buy the books that we
sometimes review on this podcast um I
got them all organized on chocolate cast
calm in the book section click just
click through there it takes you to
Amazon Amazon Prime if you have it and
you know get your book good way to
support
if you do another shopping continue do
your shopping buy that lawnmower you've
been meaning to buy also subscribe to
the podcast if you haven't already it
seems obvious I know iTunes stitcher
Google Play Spotify and other podcasting
providing podcast providing platforms
also in YouTube because we do have a
youtube channel Rob Jim I know you're on
there sometimes we have excerpts I think
that's really one of the main values is
the excerpts our first podcast because
yes yeah because a lot of times I mean
aside from seeing what you and our
guests yeah look like you know the video
version or whatever the excerpts are
shareable and I didn't realize how
valuable that was with the sharing until
one I think it's a gradually increasing
understanding of the value overall
nonetheless I could go into you know the
but let's say like hey could you make an
excerpt of this to make an excerpt for
this and make yeah you're just starting
to realize that maybe they had a reason
for that
we'll just say I'm realizing it more
hack nonetheless good value there in my
opinion and a good way to support so
subscribe to the YouTube channel if you
want also Jocko as a store if you didn't
know already
it's called jaw closed or go to jaw
closed or calm and if you want the
shirts that say discipline equals
freedom get after it
the warrior kids shirt like this one mmm
or they should always wear is the
victory I'm a man fitness that's where
he can get it that's where you get it
chuckles store comp we need to make gray
ones of these great yeah it's great
great Oh like yeah they're gray I don't
care I'm just wondering gray can we do
that yeah but that's a general term you
know greats like you can't just say hey
you know you get it I need gray shirts
for the summer time that's coming
everything I got it there are 50
different shades of pop-culture
references yeah yeah 50 shades you know
nonetheless
I'll make the gray one so there will be
a great victory MMA and
fitness shirt available on Jaco
store.com soon I like it I promise
also some women's stuff on there some
patches I just got the patches reordered
so they should be in there you know
starts running better now it is so you
know check it up we are happy to hear
that yeah man yeah it means a lot to us
yep somebody's on there some rash guards
on there for various activities
including but not limited to jiu-jitsu
cycling there was a guy on Twitter
Instagram I think he ran I think a
marathon
I think nice representing with the
representing big time we could get after
a ration card he said he did it 50%
better
50% better well there you go so boom
rash guard yes jaw closed or calm
look at that stuff I'm not saying buy
something saying if you want something
get something good way to support also
psychological warfare explain what it is
again there's no problem for me it is an
album not a music album
it's a spoken word album with tracks and
these tracks are for they have a purpose
not just entertainment like ooh this
poetic it is poetic but that's not the
purpose the purpose is for each track is
to get you through when you're on the
path on the campaign against weakness
you'll run into these moments of
weakness right just little insert
weakness insurgents if you will you know
they show up every once in a while so
you listen to a specific track
designated for a certain type of
weakness that will creep in and the
track is Jaco telling you why you should
overcome this weakness why kind of how
is well it's not chuckle yelling at you
it's just a pragmatic kind of in a
wastes these steps to take to overcome
these weaknesses boom 100% 100%
hundred percent 100% uh well you saw
success rate on that one
in my experience hundred percent good
weed support you can also get jockle
white tea on amazon it's called choco
white tea sure and that's for people
that want to deadlift eight thousand
pounds and this is another
scientifically proven factually
double-blind plot placebo placebo proven
somebody on or I don't wanna say
somebody okay there's this guy he deadly
I don't know he dead lifted a bunch oh
yes yes what's it who's that guy he's
huge he's a yarn for yeah yeah yeah
classic so I've been seeing a lot of
that video in there yeah to know a lot
of are a lot of people are wanting to
test him aqua white tea oh yeah yeah
they don't know Yuki you won't test it
does some test positive yeah yeah so
he's only the test is the deadlift yeah
they only did a little bit yeah they
smell those things before yeah so that's
chocolate white tea you can get that but
that's coming in a can
yeah by the way but it's gonna it's in
starting production it takes a long time
but by the summer time you'll be getting
Chaka white tea in a can like them right
like one of the other energy drinks that
just fill you with sugar and get you
crazy
now this is gonna fill you with
antioxidants a little bit of caffeine
and some good tastes so yeah that's
coming let's see what else books
speaking of books on Amazon or wherever
way the warrior kid you you should have
that book for all children right
is there any children is there any child
in the world that doesn't need way of
the warrior kid no didn't think so so
get that and speaking away the weather
kid there's a new way of the warrior kid
that is out right now available for
pre-order so get it and one of the
things that I would like to do everyone
tells me things like
everyone should get way of the warrior
kid every kid should read this book
every kid should read this book in high
school or in in their school people say
that to me all the time because it's
very simple clear lessons that everybody
should absorb and it would help it would
help me if I had that book it would help
everybody when they had that if they had
that book when they were younger so I
want to get this book out there in to
more kids one of the best ways to do
that if you order way the warrior kid to
Mark's mission to order it from
different sources get it from Amazon get
it from Barnes Noble
go to your local bookstore and say hey
can you please order this book for me we
want to get it spread out where a bunch
of different outlets are seeing the
demand for it that will increase the
publicity that the book receives and it
will get into more kids hands that's my
goal is to get more kids to read way the
word kid and to read marks mission so do
that it's alive also speaking to warrior
kids if you want to support a warrior
kid there's a warrior kid that's a
farmer and a businessman and he's making
soap from goat milk why cuz he's getting
after it
you can order some of that at Irish Oaks
ranch calm and the motto because he
makes he doesn't just make so he makes
Jocko so sure yeah hey he wanted to make
good soap Dave yeah I quote I want to
make good soap G ood capitalized yeah so
he makes Jocko soap smells like coconut
by the way really yeah as I like the XML
of coconut yeah is there cooking in it
here yes I didn't find it to smell like
coconut it smells it do it definitely
you don't think it smells like coconut
well maybe you have a more sensitive
Hawaiian yeah olfactory factory scent
situation yeah
but the motto from Jacques Cousteau stay
clean
you know discipline equals freedom Field
Manual again you know I was traveling
around I assigned a lot of these books
and I just traveled around when I was in
Australia a lot of people brought it in
and that was awesome a lot of great
feedback one thing that's good if you
have that book and you like it and help
you get it for someone else that you
know that that wants to get on the path
or should be on the path so that's
pretty easy to do also the audio version
of that book does not exist on
audible.com it exists on iTunes Amazon
music Google Play other mp3 platforms
it's an album with tracks sure that's
why we did it that way
and finally of course extreme ownership
the new version of extreme ownership is
out look black one which looks cool it's
got a little extra new beginning and
it's got an excerpt of qat from this
podcast in the back which is solid how
long is that part of it I don't see I
mean you know how much I think there's
eight questions I mean in there you know
answers which is pretty robust and so
it's fairly robust yeah yeah
and speaking of leadership we have a
company national on front we solve
problems through leadership that's what
we do and we do it all the time it's me
Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave Burke you
can email info at echelon front comm or
you can go to our website
excellent front comm and of course there
is the muster which is a leadership
gathering a leadership seminar a
Leadership Conference what do you learn
there pragmatic leadership skills so you
can win that's what you learned we're
only doing two this year we're doing one
in Washington DC you come in May 17th
and 18th yeah okay so you can come meet
V Rob Jones and then we're doing one in
San Francisco October 17th and 18th the
DC one by the way right now is already
it's more than half sold out right now
so these are both gonna sell out just
like all the events that we've done have
sold out so if you want to come register
as quick as you can
extreme ownership calm we'll see you
there and until the muster if you want
to hang with us
we are on the interwebs we are on
Twitter we are on Instagram and we are
on that's easy boy
echo is at Echo Charles I am at Jocko
Willie can of course Rob Jones is at Rob
Jones journey and he also has Rob Jones
journey calm and on top of that Rob
Jones has his own podcast now episode
he's one episode deep boom one episode
deep once he's on the TAF yeah the
podcast is called used to wait yep
that's good yeah I remember the way
which is wait till you see the logo yeah
yeah so you can get that wherever mp3 or
sorry podcasts are available I've
listened to the first episode you talked
about getting after it
oh yeah and yeah you talk about how to
get through a lot of things so it's it's
awesome can I add to that yeah it's kind
of an advice style podcast right now
where people asking me questions so all
those people listen to this you know
you're sendin question after question to
Jocko and he just refuses to answer he
reads it and then just throws it in the
trash
but yeah if anybody has questions that
they want to get answered by me then
send them to me at Rob Jones journey at
gmail.com or through my website or
through social media and I will answer
them use gave out your website on this
that's awesome yeah that's my special
email it's not like my person that's my
o mail that I give out first stuff like
this it also helps to keep it kind of
separated so all my questions I can just
check out oh yeah have to sift dang yeah
I got to learn now listen
they miss anything else from your
various platforms I mean I am working on
a book - Oh awesome it's there's no real
you know date - release date or anything
but I'm hoping it's gonna be a book
about veterans and the positive and just
continuing to create that story that I
was talking about earlier about pods
telling that side of the coin about
veterans that come home and are fine
yeah and I'm how it's gonna be right now
I'm kind of making it kind of like you
ever read anything by by Plato
yeah just like basically all of his
writing is conversations that Socrates
had so I'm hoping I'm gonna make it kind
of like that where it's just basically
just a series of conversations between
two people you know what's and this I
just thought that's why you were saying
this because I think this is another
important thing about on that exact
subject and we were talking earlier
about these two categories of like the
vet comes that comes home and he's good
and the vet that comes home and he's a
little a little bit off track yeah but I
would like to say and I know you're
gonna agree with us a hundred percent
just because you're a little bit off
track doesn't mean you're gonna get you
you can't easily get back on track or
I've known all kinds of veterans that
they they were off track a little bit
for a little while and then they figure
it out and they get back on track they
find a new mission so you know the guys
and that's actually fairly common in my
in motto from what I've seen and
actually talking to a lot of guys that
that went through Vietnam and they've
come home from Vietnam and they were a
little messed up when I got home you
know and they got through it got over it
and got it out of their system and moved
on and again we've talked about I've
talked about this before you know when
you got done with World War two you sat
on a ship with a bunch of other vets for
six weeks and you debriefed everything
on a ride home and you got that out of
your system and you got to communicate
and you got you moved through it
mentally Vietnam they didn't have that
opportunity Vietnam it was oh yeah
you're in Vietnam today and then
tomorrow you're in San Francisco alone
by the way you're not with anybody else
you're not with any other veterans
nowadays we do a pretty good job of when
you come home you're coming home with
your unit you stay together you have
people to talk to that have the common
experience but yeah so the vets out
there that are thinking oh man I feel
like I might be one of those guys that's
not on the right track right now you can
get back on the right track and it's
it's finding your new mission and moving
down that path towards towards achieving
it
I'm just trying everything that you
possibly can like for me it's easy to
figure out what I needed to do because
there was a system in place and it's an
obvious physical injury but with the
mental injuries we don't exactly know
how to fix them yet but you just have to
keep trying this alright try talking
about with a therapist didn't work
alright I try you know hyperbolic
chambers or whatever tried this try that
for that and because just because you
tried one thing and it didn't work out
doesn't mean that you don't want to that
doesn't mean that you now are fine with
you know nightmares and stuff you just
got to keep trying everything until
everything is exhausted yeah and I'll
tell you I've I've in talking to Jordan
Peterson couple times we've had him out
here in to listening to him in reading
his book it's become very obvious to me
and it's sort of reflective of something
that Dakota Meyer said on the podcast
which is like hey there's a your your
brain your your mentality your
psychology as a system and just like
just like you have a system to move
through and you have a physical injury
to get healed or get corrected well it's
the same thing with your psychological
state and if that psychological state is
off a little bit well there's things
that there's people that know how to fix
it if you listen to when Jordans talking
about the way that he would bring
someone through a problem there's a
systematic way to do that and I never
really understood that until I started
listening to him because you know when
they descend us to the psychologist to
debrief a deployment you know for me it
was just sort of you know I had the the
negative attitude of all this I'm not
gonna tell this guy anything cuz I don't
want them to think I'm crazy and I don't
want to get you know put on whatever you
know thing and so I just was hey I'm
just gonna move forward yeah and and
that's there was sort of my I didn't and
I'll tell you when I was in that was a
very common attitude was hey look I'm
not gonna tell this this psychologist
doesn't know what I've been through so
I'm not gonna tell him anything that was
very common and again I think for me
listening to Jordan cuz I would have
been you know two years ago or a year
ago before I started listening to jordan
Peterson talk I never really saw the
connection and then it really solidified
it when I heard Dakota talking about it
saying look this is a I put the two and
two together when I heard Dakota talking
about it like there's people just like
if you wanted to get good at Olympic
lifting you'd go to an Olympic if you
try to figure that out on your own it
would take you forever and you might get
hurt you might get hurt worse whereas if
you went to a real Olympic lifting coach
and said hey I want to learn the
clean-and-jerk and the snatch they would
say okay here's we're gonna start we're
gonna start with a PVC pipe and then
we're gonna go through the motions then
we're gonna get better at this then
we're gonna do high pulse they're gonna
walk you through the whole system and
and a psychologist will do that with
your brain they'll say okay I see what
you're scared of needles as the example
George Peters again here's what we're
gonna do to get you used to needles well
when you come back from a traumatic
event here's some things that we can do
to to revisit that and I think the same
thing that you talked about earlier with
like movies I think that part of my
prejudice against psychologists came
from the way that they're portrayed in
movies as being like you know he's
sitting on this couch and like these
weird people that you know and and it's
not it's more pragmatic than that at
least it seems that way to me so like a
trainer kind of like a trainer more like
a more like a coach right more like a
coach or more like a jujitsu instructor
yeah that's saying like hey here's what
you need to do here you get caught in
this position here's what you do the
psychologist says oh you're having
you're having bad dreams about this ok
let's try these things I don't know what
those things are cuz I don't know not a
psychologist but they do know they do
know what to tell you to do and they do
know how to help you get through those
things and just like jujitsu or just
like athletic training or just like
Olympic lifting it's gonna vary for
different people and a good
psychological coach is gonna have a know
how to make those adjustments and say oh
you're feeling this a little bit more oh
it's because you came from this kind of
family so
this is what's gonna help you but you
came from a different kind of family so
this is gonna help you a little
different way so I think those things
are important to think about and again
and I just wanted to re-emphasize the
point that just because you might be in
a rut as a either as a vet or just as a
human being you know there's there's
every little decision you make you can
start moving in the right direction
and moving towards a better place oh
yeah in your life and everything that
you're doing so I just wanted to bring
that out echo you got any other anything
else all good
good to see you again it's so awesome to
be here just be included among the the
people that you guys deem worthy of you
know takes a long time to do this it
takes a lot of preparation it's just for
you guys to to take that time and and
spend it on preparing to have me as a
guest it's a it's a huge compliment your
honor honor for us do you got any other
closing thoughts yeah I just want to
point out that you know I'm the one here
in the hot seat and I'm getting all the
accolades and but you know I didn't I
didn't do anything that I've
accomplished without people helping me I
like to it's kind of like a pyramid like
I'm the tip of the pyramid I'm like the
the thing that everybody likes to see
and that's at the top of the pyramid but
there's a whole gigantic base underneath
this pyramid that if the tip didn't have
it then the tip would just be a stupid
rock and so you know I all the way since
my recovery and I've had supporting
people and my family and especially on
this month of marathons thing I just did
if if my wife hadn't been there if Pam
hadn't been there then it's not
happening at all I mean there's some
things that I could say you know I could
have done it but it wouldn't been as
good but this thing would not have
happened without her she I mean I
totally gave her the reins why you know
set it up and if there was any question
she had about overall you know vision
for what I was trying to accomplish he
would ask me but like when we had a
couple hiccups along the way and I just
totally a hundred percent trusted her
that she
be able to take care of it and she did
every single time and she I'm sure I'm
not giving even enough credit I'm so
there's probably a thousand things that
she did I don't even know about yet but
I mean I just owe her huge and then also
my mom the same thing you know just
being willing to withstand a month in an
RV with four people you know and
probably putting up with me being grumpy
or whatever you know in pain and stuff
and couldn't imagine having you know two
people along with me that would have
made it better or that I would have
trusted as much and then also my buddy
that drove and then just all the people
that kept me going that ran with me and
you know deemed me worthy of their time
and the people that sent me messages of
encouragement that couldn't make it out
I just Oh everybody a huge debt of
gratitude and I'm gonna do my best to
continue to keep fighting and you're in
that respect and earn that earn their
effort earn their sacrifices as much as
I can awesome
well obviously Rob it's an honor to have
you back on here again I look forward to
whatever the hell kind of crazy thing
you do next I'm not sure what it's gonna
be but I'm sure it'll be something
awesome and of course thanks to everyone
for listening to this podcast thanks to
the service men and women that are
holding the line day and night day and
night fighting against evil thanks to
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics other first responders that
are always on call always on call to
protect us here at home and to everyone
that's listening I want to refer to one
last journal entry that Rob wrote and
something that we talked about the last
time that he was on then that was using
the wait because
the weight of the world can be heavy the
weight of the challenges and the trials
of life can drive you into the ground
and that weight can wear you down and
break you but instead of letting the
weight wear you down instead of letting
the weight break you you can use the
weight to make yourself stronger to make
yourself tougher to make yourself better
and that is what I recommend everyone
does just like Rob says use the weight
now get out there and get after it and
until next time this is Rob Jones and
Ecko and Jocko